From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
You ready sir?
Sure. Great question I can be.
All right. Well good morning today is December 15th, 2015. This is David Klein from the History Department at Virginia Tech.
Also working with the Southern oral history program at UNC Chapel here. Hill.
And we are here this morning as part of the Civil Rights History Project of the Library of Congress.
This Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Southern oral history program.
And I have the great honor of being with General Julius Bechtung this morning.
And if you could just introduce yourself and this is the only time I'll script you at all.
A full sentence to start with I am or that my name is.
I'm Julius Wesley Bechtung Jr. Lieutenant General United States Army Richard.
Thank you. Happy.
Thank you sir.
So let's just if we start with the where you are born and raised in a little bit about your family.
And then we'll have a conversation and take it from that.
Okay. I was born in Brinmore, Pennsylvania.
I went to high school in Lower Marrying in high school. I just point that out because there are a few rather prominent graduates of Lower Marrying.
The Library of Congress has an example of Jim Billington, Al Hague of some notoriety, Hap Arnold, the former Commander of the Air Force, the former Air Corps.
If you live here in Washington, the anchor on Channel 4 is a graduate of Lower Marrying.
And we have other some prominent citizens.
Kobe Bryant, some people have never heard of him.
I understand he's retiring this year.
So we have that kind of program.
We have some outstanding academics at one time.
Lower Marrying was in the top 10 of the high schools in the country and they're still very hard now.
And they have a great reputation.
I'm happy to say that I get out of that place.
It will.
And this is what they call the main line.
The main line to fill it off you.
It's supposed to be, not supposed to be, is it very gritty and well to do.
I was born there because my father was a janitor in the department.
And we lived in the basement of the department.
And it's a block and a half from Brinmore College.
And two blocks from Brinmore Trees station that goes out from Philadelphia.
It's a very other schools, Rolls-Mount, Villanova, Kavrford, Swapwood,
just some of the schools that are in that area.
So they grew up in an academic field.
Right.
And what were the sort of restraints or boundaries of race and class in that area as you were growing up?
It was part of the segregation areas.
However, the schools were not segregated.
We could not go into certain restaurants or could not.
We go to the theater.
We were required to sit down in front rows.
And if there were fill, we just, depending on how much the field would feel,
the film would be going.
We could remember, Mangle with Red the Folk, they wouldn't complain about it.
But it was segregated.
We're talking now back in the 20s and 30s.
It took some time to get through all of those things.
And so you had your high school years there.
And high school years, the Lord of Marys located in Arbor, Pennsylvania.
It's a township.
There were very few things we could not do.
We could not participate in the swimming program.
I do not remember in the four years I was in high school, county, ninth grade,
having gone to a prom.
It wasn't encouraged.
So we did not bother doing it.
We did not have to work in the four schools.
We were concerned academically.
We were encouraged to do the best we could.
I happen to have been a member of the student council.
The president of my class.
We started kindergarten together and he'll be invited to my birthday party.
We go back that four.
Wonderful.
So after high school, after high school, I joined the Army Air Corps listed reserves
and I was a senior at Lord of Married.
And when I graduated, I came on to do the, what year was this?
1944 when I came on to do the, my first duty station was the Luxe Mississippi,
T-Street Air Force Base.
As I sometimes say with tongue and cheek, I greet a place for young black 18 years old to go to in those times.
And taking the physical examination for flight school, I flunked the ice test.
I had stigmatism.
I knew I had that problem.
But when I walked into my testing in every other place, they had a big chart in a wall, big E, and then scale down.
And those days I could take one look at that chart and I had it memorized.
Front back either way.
They said, okay, cover your right eye, cover your right eye.
Cover the left eye, fine.
I got down a Keesler field, new machine, technology.
In a darkened room with a machine right back here, and you walk in, I don't see any chart.
Room dark.
They pushed a button.
The chart comes up.
I had no chance.
I flunked the test.
And that sent me off to McDillfield, which was an Army Aviation Facility Engineer.
What had you been hoping you might be able to do?
I wanted to become a pilot in what turned out to be a Tuskegee Airman.
Didn't have that name when I was there.
I wanted to become a pilot because half-barnal had come out to our high school and convinced us
to join the Army Air Corps when you're civil-winging and goal bars.
And I got out, I went down, and after he finished his spiel, about half the football team went down to take the battery of tests.
Six of us passed.
And on the 28th of December, 1943, we were all inducted into the Army Air Corps and let's the reserves.
And that's how I got into the flight program in the first place.
After going through Newcoma, Newcoma-Landwood with the reception station, I went to a Kiesler field.
My five other buddies went to Florida.
Kiesler went ahead, black Americans, to Florida, they did not have.
And so I might add that none of us became pilots for various reasons.
After that, off the McDeal field, Army Engineering.
Well, let me ask first, you said it tongue in cheek, blocks you not the best place perhaps to be.
Could you tell us a little bit about what conditions were there?
For example, the one weekend I took off, we leave from Kiesler field, the buddy of mine, and I went down to Kiesler,
to Biluxy, rather, from the base.
And while walking down the street, we heard some noise coming from the rear.
There are two of them.
And we turned around here, and the pickup truck coming down to payment, driving at us.
We flat the guest walls, and they went by.
And we thought it may be a good idea to get back on post.
And so we did.
And that was typical treatment, treatment.
And I pointed out because many years later, I went back to Biluxy.
I am now a Lieutenant General United States Army.
I was invited back by the National Guard of Mississippi.
I was greeted by the Agent General.
I flew in in my own aircraft, the Army's aircraft, rather, which I control.
I was greeted by this AG.
We went from the airfield to a small camp that they had, and I forget to name it, a base, the Army of the Camp, rather.
I spent the night there, and then we drove to the hotel where they had a meeting of National Guard,
and reservists, for which I was to speak to.
And my first comment, my health, things have changed.
And I explained what I was talking about.
The last time I was down here, let me tell you what happened to me.
And of course, all of them knew and understood what I was exactly talking about.
I had a State Trooper escort from the airport to this camp, to the hotel, left in great fashion.
But that wasn't a significant change.
Still is not the best at a time, but it would help a lot better than when I was first there.
What were the barracks like in 1944?
It wouldn't build, wouldn't buildings, two story.
Just like everyone else, but we were separated from the rest of the post.
Control by the camp.
My company commander was a white, first lieutenant.
He had a white, exec, and the rest were black.
First Sergeant, the rest of the cadres.
As a matter of fact, it was there after I got down to McDill,
one of the engineering, aviation engineering unit.
And with the same setup, basically, structure.
The first Sergeant had been, was told by a public exec, that he's hurt,
that there was an announcement for, application of OCS.
And that fellow back to I understand was an aviation cadet.
He might be interested.
But at that time, I had become the first Sergeant's clerk.
How did I become his clerk?
One very wet day.
The first Sergeant came out and said, okay.
I need a clerk.
I need a volunteer.
Who can type?
I had typing as a club from a hand up.
Okay, come here.
Let's go in.
Went into the first Sergeant's office.
I found out that the first Sergeant had a little problem.
My job was to read the company roster to him, the company roster,
because he could not read.
And he had it memorized, basically.
He would get up in front of the company and put that paper up and call the role.
That's a fewer reading.
That's the kind of Army we had at that time.
And because I was able to type and help him, you're my clerk.
Yes, first Sergeant.
And when his lieutenant came back from post, he said, there's a roster.
There's a campaign or statement on a board, vote and board at post,
that it could be an OCS application board.
You might, be sure it might be interested.
First Sergeant came in and said, you're going to go down and take a test.
You're going to go down and appear at board.
Yes, first Sergeant.
I went down.
And this is one of the weird things.
The President of the board had been through the township of Lormarion.
And when I mentioned that I had gone to Lormarion, played football there,
I had at least one person on my side.
I didn't do poorly, but that made me feel pretty good when I was trying to answer the questions.
That's how I started my process out of Tisler, out of Baluxy,
out of McDill Field.
And I passed the OCS test, passed the board.
And in January of 45, I went off to Fort Benning, infantry OCS.
I got there in these semis, in fact, in 1944.
School started in January of 45.
And I graduated from OCS in August of 45.
15 August in Marifold.
In the interesting part, they had dropped a bomb.
We were destined to go off to become infantry lieutenants.
And Marifold, when Germany quit about April of 45,
we started getting concerned because, hey, they might cut off OCS,
and there was no job.
We were on key OCS going.
As a result, when the Japanese dropped it, they said, well, we're just close.
They wouldn't there cut out OCS now.
They didn't, and we graduated on 16 August of 45.
I was sent off briefly to Alabama from basic training, duty.
And within three weeks, I was off to Pacific.
Well, yeah.
Now, OCS is sort of a quirk.
OCS is not, we're not segregated, correct?
No, Officer Kennedy School.
Right.
And they had Officer Kennedy School.
And it's designed to fill these void when they drop off sufficient,
not going to the official officers coming out of West Point,
or ROTCs, and there's still a need for more officers,
Officer Kennedy School to group that they turned to.
Right.
And that was an integrated.
That was integrated.
Yeah.
When I got there, integrated to a point.
You always have to make sure that you're clear.
I got inside the Officer Kennedy Regiment.
We were just like everyone on every other soldier.
Our training, we lived in integrated billets.
We can integrate everything.
However, you step outside of that regiment ever.
You're back to the south.
You waited in your line to get on a certain bus.
Even there going to the theater, outside the region area.
You set a different location in your fellow candidates.
But inside the training itself, completely integrated.
And were there service clubs on the base?
Yes, service clubs in the base.
But we went to a black service club.
And my white counterparts went to the white service club.
Same thing for the Officer, Officer Club.
And it was the southern way of doing business.
Okay.
So what then off to the Pacific?
Off to the Pacific, joined a 93rd Infantry Division.
All black divisions except for the division commander and his T-staff.
One of the more interesting parts about that.
We would overseas on a, well fortunately back up a little bit.
Before leaving the States, I went to a place staging area in California.
And I'm grouping now for the name of it.
But it was the place to go from that staging area overseas.
I met a couple of, or about 15 of us officers.
Two of them were Westponders.
And we became very good friends while we're in route to the Pacific.
So much so that they convinced me doing our transit.
If I ever had chance to go to Westpoint, I wouldn't do it.
Or I had my commission.
And I was not about to go through what they had to go through.
The sourcing treatment and the other things.
They also taught me how to shoot crap.
They took my money because they taught me how to shoot crap on a blanket.
If you know anything about shooting crap, that's the last thing you want to do.
And they took my money from that.
And I reminded them of that later when I had a chance.
Went off to the Pacific.
The war just over.
But there still were, I went to a place called Moritai, which is Southfoot,
the Philippine, North of New Guinea.
There were two divisions on Moritai.
The 93rd Division and the Diction Division.
Why the Army put those two divisions together?
I'll never know.
I tried to find out since then.
No one has given me a satisfactory answer.
But during the fighting, they did very well against the bad guy, the Japanese.
Keeped his mind as a war not going on.
We're fighting the Japanese.
When there were no fighting going on with the Japanese, they fought each other.
So much so that I was pulled out of my regiment.
I was in C Company, first battalion, three-sixth in Infantry,
and sent on detail to the Poes Marshall and the Diction Division had a lieutenant come up,
and we rode patrols together to try to make sure maintain a little bit of peace.
Peace between the two.
Keep in mind, I was 19-year-old, second lieutenant.
This guy from Diction Division, the same age I was, so we were two characters stuck out there.
Driving around in a Jeep.
To drive around and keep peace.
Another interesting situation.
The Diction Division flying Confederate flags and all your things like this.
Confederate flag as well, regimental flag.
One of my combat activities was required to take a patrol into the hills,
and the new to Japanese were someplace up in the hills, up in the mountain.
The war was over, so we had Japanese translator.
We went out, I had my platoon.
The Japanese translator had a bullhorn, announcing the fact that war is over, give up,
come on, we'll take care of you.
For that, we got shot at, and we were told not to engage.
We had weapons to protect ourselves, but do not engage.
We got shot at, we knew where they were, came back, report that to the battalion commander.
He in turn reports that the regiment commander said, hey, no, the New York commander said,
they're up there, we know where they are, we'll just start them out.
That took her my first combat experience being shot at.
That went on for time to deactivate the division, January of 46.
If you had a certain number of quality points, or overseas points, you came home.
I did not have any of those things, I just got in there.
I, in the field, felt the respect to the technical services.
I went to Manila as a signal unit.
I reported in company.
There were six officers, company commanders are captain.
I went to junior, Lieutenant of the Chemical Command was an infantry officer.
The three officers were signal officers, and rest of them were infantry.
This is a heavy construction company, the kind of company that goes out and put them overhead wire and cable.
Jolder holes in the ground, put into holes, and then string cable.
I never drilled, I never been in a signal unit before, but one very much difficult.
I knew what I had to do.
I had a platoon of 30 odd soldiers.
All of them were signal officers, signal soldiers, and they were happy to get a youngster in that could help them with many things.
So they taught me how to climb holes, how to go up there, hang wire.
We drilled a lot, I taught them how to do that.
I did something the other lieutenants would not do.
I climbed a pole and checked it out.
We had a chance on one occasion to put in poles for, we're talking now Manila for radio or commercial.
Radio of televisions too.
We put in 100 foot poles.
You put in 100 foot poles, you got about 10 feet into the ground.
Once you get the pole to ground, now you have to go up and hang the wire.
I didn't have much choice to go up or stay down.
My soldier up hanging wire, I'm going to climb a pole too.
I have never, I don't like heights.
I got up that pole, went to the top of it.
Sold what they were doing and came back down.
Now, if you know anything about pole climbing, pole climbing, if you do 10 to 4 or slip,
the last thing you want to do is grab.
You push yourself away from the pole and you have gaps on your feet and shoes,
which forces you fit into the pole and keeps you from falling.
My other lieutenant wouldn't go up.
My part too was so happy, moving to the company, he said, my lieutenant does that.
Look at him.
Well, I went up once, have not been up that high again on the pole.
What I proved I could do it.
And that's the way we operated.
The company commander, as I said, was an infantry captain who later ran across in other services.
My tour there ended when I was reached at going home,
separated in 46, came home, went to,
I stayed in reserves, although I could have been separated.
If I just felt like what I was doing, I stayed in reserves.
In order to do that, I had to become a signal officer because I was infantry transferred to signal corps,
doing an assignment, and when the reserve went into signal officer.
State acted in the reserves and went to reserve training.
I had a chance to go to college.
Mine you had no college at this time.
I had a role in Lincoln University in Oxford, Pennsylvania, Lincoln College, excuse me.
And at the week that I was supposed to report for class, which would have been in February of 47,
I got a call from my whole football coach, Laura Marion.
How would you like to go to Muleenberg?
We're in the health Muleenberg.
So now in town, Pennsylvania, why Muleenberg?
They got an excellent pre-med program.
I went to the doctor at that time, and I said, hmm, okay.
Sure.
And so I went to Muleenberg College.
At first, black American had gone to Muleenberg.
I was on a football scholarship, and I used to collect about $38 a month stipend.
We still care of my internals.
So you, so rather than go to Lincoln, which is next BCU, maybe the first thing to see you.
I went to Muleenberg.
In Allentown, for black student, did very well as a matter of fact.
How were, let me back up a little bit.
Muleenberg, this is, I went there in February of 57, excuse me, 47.
And the coach at Muleenberg had just gotten there.
He came from a prep program, prep school, and he brought a couple of the old players,
and they were really good players.
He had spring practice, and we're out there under the lights, spring practice, contact.
You know, injured myself, my shoulders, part of the reason I injured myself,
and how it happened, my equipment was not properly fitted.
The trainers who gave me equipment, that gave me inappropriate equipment,
and I suffered shoulder separation.
They purposely gave that to you.
I also understand, that's why I ended up getting it, this is what it went.
And I couldn't play football anymore.
And I decided then that I really don't need this because I was doing quite well academically.
And I found out that I could stay in college.
I was there on the GI Bill of Rights, so I didn't need to, Monday for that standpoint.
I didn't need to $30, $31 for stip for insininels.
So I just dropped my scholarship, football scholarship, and got a series of upplaying academics.
Of course, I forgot to mention, between the time I got home, they went to Mulebert.
I met a young nurse from Severnfield, of the Uofia.
She was in nursing training, and we decided to get married.
So in 48, January of 48, 29th of January, 48, we had our wedding.
I'll point out that morning, day before that, I had taken a final exam in analytical geometry.
I'm a pre-med student, and I did not do well.
As a matter of fact, I went into that test, I read the questions, re-read them.
In my answer on the street, I wrote down, re-wrote the question, and took a guess on each question,
and turned in, and the professors called me and said,
you know you didn't do well.
Yes, sir. I know exactly what you've done.
You have been memorizing formulas, analytical geometry, and he's right.
I've been memorizing, not understanding it.
Up until that time, I've been doing quite well.
He said, okay, you've been making A's, but I'm going to give you a B,
but of course, because you've flown the final exam.
Yes, sir. I understand that.
The very next day I had my wedding.
And a lot of friends say, I know you've flown the test.
You're getting married.
So that makes a long story short.
We got married in 29th of January, and started off on our honeymoon,
and on, we just had a great time.
I might add to honor honeymoon, which is a rather unique story.
My brother, who, younger than I, but had dropped out of school during World War II,
joined the Navy, frustrated his parents, and everyone else.
But he had dropped, he ran away from home a couple of times,
so mom was convinced that he would not do well staying there.
So he went to join the Navy.
She approved him to join the Navy.
And he went off going off to college.
And he was going to college and show you the rest of you in North Carolina.
To get down there, we were driving down.
And so my mother drove the car, and my brother Joe, my wife Louise,
and I went down.
A unique story.
Your mother going on your honeymoon, but that's the way we operate in those days.
And dropped the more, came back up, and everything went fine from then.
But that was in January of 48.
State did quite well in school.
Harry Truman, later that year, issued the executive order 9981 to integrate the military.
I really had enjoyed being in the military, and I was in training camp
that everything improving ground during the summer when the order was issued.
And I came back home and told my wife, well, I'll have a chance to go back to the actor duty.
And I really liked what I was doing.
And I could not be a doctor any hell.
I wasn't doing well in chemistry, which not very good for a doctor.
So she was happy to satisfy with because she was a nurse working.
So we weren't going to starve.
While I was at Aberdeen Proving Ground when the order was issued,
the commander of the post called all the officers together.
He read the executive order signed by the president.
And after he finished, and Aberdeen body was a completely integrated post,
read the executive order.
He called the duty officer.
And he said, as long as I'm here, there'd be no change.
And by that, he meant officer club number one, officer club number two.
Swimming pool number one, swim pool number two, NCO club number one, NCO club number two.
All the ones are white, all the two are black.
And doing his very, as the commander, after the orders issued, no change.
So when I went back on act of duty, we were expecting our first child.
I was now at, I was on orders to a signal unit, signal unit at Fort Bliss Texas.
I was recalled as an infantry officer because I wanted to go to infantry.
Part of my interruption, but I just wanted to follow up.
Having heard the president's executive order,
and I imagine having some reaction to that and hope for a career possibility is opening up.
And then hearing the response of the commander, the post commander,
can you walk me through the range of feelings that you went through?
Well, let me back up a little bit of history.
World War I.
The black soldiers were fighting in segregated units.
The commander and Europe, parsing did not want black troops.
Black Command.
So, $369 by unit in World War II had fought with the French because they preferred, they wanted us.
And it will.
Came back well rewarded.
And when a $369 got back in the States, they were not greeted as heroes,
but they came back through New York and jeered.
In 1925, I could be off by a year.
There was a study done at Carlisle Barrett, the Army War College,
basically saying that the black soldiers, while they may be good,
doing steeper-daw work,
laboring, they were not good for
thinking through a project or being able to officially control soldiers
and could not do certain other things, technical things.
That study stayed around for a long time.
So, when World War II came along, that was the mentality of the officer corps,
of leadership, of the war department.
There was no reason to change it.
When B.O. Davis became a fighter pilot, he had some major problems,
but because in 1993, the 99 pursuit squadron did very well.
We were able to shoot down aircraft and not lost any aircraft,
not lost a fighter that day were escorting, or a permanent escorting.
So, it didn't surprise me or anyone else that there were certain beliefs
in the military, leaders that, not just the president, that we can do,
this is our Army, and we're gonna do what we wanna do.
May I point out today in 2015,
you have attitudes where folks are saying one thing,
and the president is saying something else?
It's not much different.
So, the Army, soldiers and leaders are doing what they're told to do,
and once the word came out, and it set the mind to do certain things,
to get on with the program.
Their job is to be loyal.
And no one contested that I know of this post commander.
I'm not too sure that the Army, what department knew about it?
I'm a lieutenant, I'm not gonna get up there and challenge it,
no one else would have challenged it, so.
I left that post, by the way, when I'm ahead of myself now,
but what he had it to was, when.
In the executive order didn't have a timeline, it just.
No, yeah, yeah.
It basically said, as I recall,
I can look at that book over here,
I got the order in there, but basically said,
we've all delivered speed.
Very similar to the brand decision, all delivered speed.
And so, I'm now back on Acta-Duty,
went to Fort Bliss as a signal officer.
I had applied for infantry, and I had applied to become a regular Army officer.
The difference between being a regular Army officer and a reserve officer is,
I hope, it's understood.
It's a way to go if you're gonna be a career soldier.
Well, I Fort Bliss, I was in a signal unit company.
I was a junior officer,
and our job was to go from Fort Bliss to Fort Bright,
and participate in a maneuvers.
To do this, you got to drive by road,
and we took our signal unit, trucks and all,
from Fort Bliss to Fort Bright,
and as I said, I'm the junior officer,
so I'm the guy in charge of the Messhall kitchen.
My job with the book of cooks took a while, cooked,
and when the soldiers joined us,
feed them, and then move to the next point,
while they're coming along behind us, cook, prepare a meal for them,
select a bib like area.
Driving by road from El Paso to Fort Bright,
it's not easily done.
We don't have your radio communication.
We're signal unit, but we don't do a radio,
which is telephone.
The very first place out, Van Horn, Texas,
very unique place.
They didn't cut into blocks at all,
no matter where an army or not.
It so happened that I had a,
I'd going out, set up our bill of act area,
set up the kitchen,
did a cooking, when the company came in,
then I had to take a listing of things,
one thing wanted from downtown.
Okay, that's easy.
I took a list of things they wanted,
of course, soldiers want things that don't provide,
like cigarettes, candy, and you name it,
I had a list.
I went down to a local drug store
and I gave a list to the store owner,
and he was happy,
he was gripping a list of things he could sell.
And you're in uniform?
I was in uniform, I clearly feel uniform.
I went to the fountain,
sort of fountain,
where they make ice cream,
and stuff like that.
I often join myself,
and my sergeant who would be
was collecting things that we were going to buy.
All of a sudden, the guy behind the counter,
stiffened up,
I had a paint shirt,
and the next thing they got,
a chap me on the shoulder,
get away from the counter.
Why?
I said so.
I turned around,
gripping bad chair,
and a great big fellow in uniform with a weapon.
And,
okay,
I understood what he was saying,
and I understood why he said it.
And I said to the sergeant,
have we paid for anything yet?
No sir.
Okay, we're leaving.
And we walked out.
And the sheriff had gotten back to the bid bike area,
by the way, I forgot to mention my company commander was a major white.
He got back to the bid bike area,
and the sheriff had gotten there before I got there.
And he had told this,
the sheriff would tell him,
this major that this boy you got over here,
doesn't understand what goes on down here.
The major said,
that boy is a lieutenant,
he's not from here.
He's doing what I told him to do.
And he said,
he better tell him something differently while he's here.
Okay?
Sheriff left.
I get back.
I told what took place.
The very next morning,
we're heading out,
continuing our route.
And a sedan,
stood a baker,
as a matter of fact,
had an accident.
It passed us flying like a bad out of hell.
And I had, by the way,
a Jeep and a three-quarter tonne,
just called pickup truck type thing.
He passed us like a bad out of hell,
had an accident,
a clover.
And we get up there to where it was,
so what happened?
Took the emergency rounds,
we took the two women
out of the truck,
out of the cars,
pulling up pickup truck,
and I continued in my Jeep,
on my way,
my truck took the women back to the hospital in Van Horn, Texas.
The doctors said that the action of these soldiers
saved these women.
And when the sheriff came into the hospital
to hear what the accident started,
checking on,
wondering, okay, how did it happen?
Who brought them back?
And my sergeant,
who had whipped me the night before,
that lieutenant,
who you chased out of town
to wanted to save these women lives.
There was a message there too.
We went on our way from there on time,
that on to Fort Bragg.
But that was a unique experience for me,
to go through that.
It changed the minds of some people too,
to include that sheriff.
Hey, maybe it's not all bad for these soldiers.
That went on until we went to,
we got to Fort Bragg,
went through the drill,
putting in communications.
It was shortly thereafter,
my orders came through,
my assignment came through
to go to a infantry unit.
And I was then transferred from the 29th signal to
the second division at Fort Lewis, Washington,
on competitive tour,
competing for a regular army appointment.
And we did quite well at Fort Lewis,
still a segregated unit.
The division,
9th infantry regiment,
had three battalions.
One battalion was black,
yellow to battalion were white.
I was assigned to
the first battalion in the
United States,
ill company,
third battalion,
ninth infantry.
We trained and were prepared to
keep going we're doing.
And the Korean War broke out.
So I was just asking about the facilities.
Right, at Fort Lewis.
Ready to go again?
Yes, we're going.
At Fort Lewis,
we had a very big complement of three regiments.
And the only regiment that had blacks were
in ninth infantry.
The other two regiment did not.
And the division artillery had a black battalion.
The black battalion in the ninth infantry,
the third battalion,
as I said, was all black except for the battalion command
with black two.
Another story about that.
The battalion,
one of the sergeants,
turned out to be a pretty important person.
He became a member of the Congress,
Charlie Rangel.
That name, Ray-Ray Grbell.
Yes, it does.
He was from the battalion,
and we talked about this many times,
it's that time.
But when,
as I said, we trained very hard,
trained very hard at Fort Lewis before the war broke out.
I was among my regular duties of infantry,
and I was also in charge of the battalion later became
the regimental drill team.
And we had a tremendously fine unit.
We're not put on performances,
not only for soldier,
but also for civilians.
They did quite well.
And I got quite a reputation for doing that.
And your equipment was up to date?
The equipment was up to date, everything.
It was like the rest of the unit,
the rest of the army, but we're still black,
ourselves.
I asked for the battalion commander,
he said, go ahead and do it.
I said, let's, we got some soldiers, white soldiers,
from the rest of the regiment wanted to join our team.
I was happy with that.
But I had to go to regimental exec.
And I'll never forget what he said.
So I like the way your team, what they do.
They look good, and a good for the army,
and certainly good for the soldier.
But we put white soldiers in there,
they'll break up the parents in the color.
Lieutenant Colonel saying that, I'm a lieutenant.
How much I could say about that?
Okay, fine.
Yet, again, we're talking 19 and 50.
We trained, and right by the time when the,
in April of 1950, our battalion commander got orders
to go to, to be reassigned.
And it was the war broke out as you may recall,
in June of 50.
And he had just,
still in the post, but not moved.
And when the word came out that we got to be,
we're going to be sent overseas, alerted for war,
for combat.
We had white battalion commander in, in, now.
And we thought that the army could do the right thing,
bring our battalion commander back,
who we have before, who would train us,
did a very fine job doing that,
and put it back, put us,
with our old commander.
He was the only lieutenant Colonel,
the I knew of, they had a PhD.
He had to be a,
a suology biologist,
and doing it.
He was also a very hard-knosed person,
for demanding excellence,
and he'll fire you in a heartbeat,
and, of course, he made your problem.
But we're pleased with that, because we knew that he was on our side.
The person he brought back in to command,
with the commander that we had before he got there,
he was still doing something else.
And a lot of us thought that,
hey, bring back our commander,
because he done so well.
He didn't work that way.
Now, June of,
we're deployed, 1950,
the night infantry,
with the first unit to leave the states,
to go to Korea.
Did you know where you were going?
We know it was Korea,
did you know anything about Korea?
No, no.
I didn't know where Korea was.
Hey, I'm on.
I'm now 19.
I guess I'm about 20 by that time.
But I quickly found out where it was,
and what they were doing.
I knew what had to do with what he got there,
to be prepared to fight.
And we were on board ships,
heading off to the combat zone,
landed at Busan, Korea.
My unit was the,
elk coming with the first to land,
went into a big white area,
water rest of the battalion,
and regiment came on.
And rest of the enough,
while we're setting there,
we got work that we're going to be removed from the regiment
on a separate mission.
This is 1950,
and no one asked the question,
why I've been going to the Cape Mahire headquarters,
McArthur's headquarters,
I want to battalion to go up,
to Poehong,
to protect an airfield.
Okay.
So, as we were getting our gear ready,
I got called to regiment headquarters.
Lieutenant Beckton, we want you to take a patrol
with communication gear to set up a command,
a command post,
CP communication rather,
when we closed in,
when your battalion closed into it,
I'll never ready to go.
And so, I got my sufficient number of men,
a small platoon,
and took communication gear,
a couple of three,
pick up, three,
two and a half ton truck
with communication gear and a vacuum.
And we drove from our airfield
to the site where we were sent to protect an airfield,
protect an airfield.
And we got there,
I asked the question,
by the way,
any activity in the area?
No, no one, no bad guys there.
And we got up to Poehong Gang,
set up a command,
our gear,
and as we did that morning,
we're waiting for the battalion to join us,
and we got reported in that the battalion got ambushed,
and lost some people,
and they finally joined the area of which we were in,
the same area that we had driven through,
and the guys at Bedgah knew who we were,
they could have done serious damage,
but let us go through,
they could take our big, bigger thing later.
When we came up,
we didn't got ambushed,
and we survived that,
my first close call.
We stayed there,
had a couple patrols,
protect an airfield,
and then the orders came in
for the battalion to move back and join the regiment.
It is now September.
We're breaking out of the effort,
we're now to break out a Poehong perimeter,
which has some notoriety
that the forces were driven back into that.
And we rejoined the regiment,
and prepared to go to the serious combat.
We've had some combat up until that time.
The Ella Company was to be the lead,
a battalion,
the company battalion,
after we had joined the regiment.
My platoon got selected to be the lead,
to be in the company.
And as we were moving out,
with all of our armor
and everything else,
ran into a attacking hill call,
201.
This hill was well protected.
We got half way up the hill,
and we got ran to a tremendous enemy fire,
and had to protect ourselves
and seek cover.
And while we're there,
the adjacent battalion,
second battalion, engaged up,
because no one had told them
that U.S. forces could be out there,
one of those crazy things.
So the bad guys are fighting at us,
our battalion is firing at us,
and we had nothing to do,
but hunker down until we could night-kame.
We returned a fire on the bad guys,
and prayed that we were able to do
some damage on the bad guys,
but we got hurt.
When darkness came,
we withdrew back into the battalion area.
I had lost some people,
but we brought them with us.
But that breakthrough was sufficient
enough for our battalion to move out.
I might add that while we're in this also battle,
we had support by our Air Force.
And they took us for enemy.
So they also attacked us too,
firing a aircraft.
And no matter what we did,
they kept going on some of my messenger of mine
as a lieutenant now.
He grabbed a panel of marking panels,
and he got out in front and weaved them up and down to Air Force,
and we're coming back at us.
They understood that wrong hill,
get the next hill.
We got him on war by the way for that.
And he probably saved our lives.
The interesting part about that,
I had told my men that once we were getting combat,
we're going to step to here as a team.
Don't start running to the rear.
If you do, I'll kill you.
It's talking cheek-day thought.
And when the plane came back,
some of my soldiers start to get up and shoot.
I'm going to run, move back to the rear.
And I took a carbine, a small rifle,
an unloader magazine in front of them.
And they looked at me and looked at the planes.
And they knew that I was closer to them than the planes.
And they got back on the ground.
In the meantime, the soldiers, the fighter pilots,
also recognized that we're good guys.
And so they went elsewhere.
My soldiers got back on the ground,
and when we got back in the camp, recovered,
we had a little discussion.
Lieutenant, would you have shot us?
You're here, aren't you?
Well, yeah, you didn't keep running, did you?
No. Well, you make up your own mind.
It was also doing that period that I had gotten wounded.
And that was my first trip to the hospital.
I went back to Japan, as a matter of fact,
in up in Sendai, Japan for my recovery.
And I'm pulling that out because I came back
to join a unit as soon as I could,
because General McGarford said,
we're going to be home for Christmas.
And I want to be back at victory.
We're going to be home for Christmas.
I didn't work out that way.
I rejoined the regiment from the hospital.
And by that time, the regiment did a very good job.
It was done quite well.
We had moved north, in the North Korea.
And I was in the Natalia, the Natalia, 9th Infantry.
And one of the lead regiments in the attack going up north.
And once again, my company was selected to lead the battalion.
And it was cold, then.
Remember, we left the states in summertime.
We didn't have winter gear.
And we're now up north of the 38th parallel into North Korea.
Not too many miles from the northern border.
Again, we had our battles to do.
And it's mountainous, and it's cold.
It is, right?
And no winter gear.
But we were able to take care of ourselves.
We're now in November.
It's cold, digging in to fight, to continue to fight going north.
It was Thanksgiving time.
And I remember that, the coup, the Turkic dinner.
However, by the time the Mito got where we were,
the Turk was a little bit cold, like frozen.
And we found we take care of that, our kids and the best they could.
And we had dug in, had our fires out, trying to stay warm.
And the Chinese entered the war.
The date you can check that, find what, because it was very specific when they came in.
We contained the battle against the Chinese and the North Koreans.
I was, again, my particular pick to lead the company in the attack.
Again, we were told to record order a ground high ground in front of us.
Would you ever wonder why you kept getting chosen to lead?
Did you ever wonder why your unit kept getting chosen to go out front?
We were pretty good at it.
Yeah.
And remember, I said I was on competitive to the tour.
I was competing for regular army appointments.
So the battalion commander, even Ubatan commander, said, OK,
vectors can make it happen.
We're the only guy who can do the same thing, but no.
And my company commander, who was a pretty good friend of my dad,
he had other looters he could pick on.
But they had two of them have been in combat in World War II.
And I'm now a 20-year-old, an eager and everything else.
I had a good unit.
We trained well.
My soldiers trusted me and I trusted them.
And I held.
I was prepared to do it.
You were ready.
Yeah.
The next time, we were making a tie-up a hill.
And as I was before I left, my battalion commander had been approached by the
adjacent battalion commander from the 25th regiment, which happened to be a black unit
too on the 25th division.
And my battalion commander, we're collaborating, talking about many things, I guess.
I'm heading up the hill, running the contact.
And I was told, do not engage because you're out to buy yourself with your patrol
return to battalion.
I came off the hill and reported the battalion commander and the other battalion commander,
there's nothing up there.
I know better than that.
And my car looked at me and looked back at him.
And I got orders, okay, get back up there.
And I start back up the hill again with my unit.
This time picked up a wound.
One of the military, a thousand dollar wound.
The bullet went through between my tendon and my left ankle and the bone.
It got the tendon nor did it touch the bone.
Now how much space is down there?
Not much.
The bullet went through there.
Nothing, no damage done to either.
I came back down.
The battalion commander still there.
Are you satisfied now, Colonel?
He wrong.
I got evacuated from the battalion.
That's when history would tell you that the army had his first defeat.
When the Chinese and the North Korean attacked US forces and chased them out of North Korea.
I got evacuated by air.
The battalion and regiment suffered severe damage.
The final toll where I think is I recall,
another battalion, five officers survived.
The elder had captured a kill.
I fell into category one to five survived because I had been evacuated and now back in Japan.
The US force pushed back south for the 38th Paranole and regrouped.
I am now back in Japan, back to the same hospital I've been in before, which I rushed out of.
Went to the same war as a matter of fact.
You?
Back here again?
Yes, I'm back here again.
In this time, I'm not going to rush home.
They understood.
I got very good treatment and care.
During that period, the army regrouped, recovered, prepared to take care of business.
I was told to rebuild your strength by going out and learning how to ski.
Send I known for its slopes and stuff like that.
And so, flying, I've gone and tried.
I never ski before you understand.
Went out to the training area where they teach skiing.
And they gave me skis, flagboard, two straps, one across the insta, one across the hill.
No boots, nothing else.
And I did like you might expect you ski by the way.
Yes.
So you understand what kind of trouble I had.
I did not do very well at all.
But I managed to get back off the hill and went back to the hospital area.
But that taught me a lesson about trying to ski with that kind of equipment.
I eventually come back to the unit now in March, back to the regiment.
And the back in the base camp before I moved up to the regiment.
They had a new executive officer in the regiment.
Lieutenant Colonel Arlento, Marsani.
And you'll see why I remember that name in a few minutes.
And when I get back to the regimental rear, and I meet the battalion exec,
he enroves me to this regimental exec.
And the battalion execs said, we're going to put back to the battalion and become,
he'll put them into an S3 operation.
He's been in combat, he understands he can help us there.
Or a sign that would look at me.
Lieutenant, how you feel?
I feel pretty good, sir.
We're going to put them into a company.
Why?
Because the company picked from me was L company.
Sound familiar?
Company I was in, men and four.
They had lost all of the officers and a few of the insurgents.
They needed some leadership up there.
Battalion agent said, but sir, he just got...
He's going to go to the company.
Yes, sir.
So I ended up going back to K company, L company, excuse me.
And he's correct.
We had all the officers been gone.
We got lost.
Somebody in the open had a couple of key insurgents that knew me and I knew them.
So I'm now in the company commander.
And we organized what we had.
We had gotten some new lieutenants, second lieutenants.
Still all black or white replacements at this point.
By that time we were integrated.
I failed to mention one point.
Let me go back a little bit.
Mac in August, before I got 201 when I got my first loan,
the regiment commander, Colonel C.C. Sloan,
had been told by the adjutant we got incoming replacements,
called for up by M.O.F. military operations,
military specialties, but not by race.
And Sloan said, put them where they're needed.
Put them where they're needed.
Dr. C. took care of the integration within the NIFE infantry.
Went to the battalions, spread them out.
And when I got my first integrated soldier, he was a...
American, Mexican American, from Texas.
And when he came in, I told my patuist,
I don't let anything happen to that guy.
He's our first one non-blank.
We're not going to hurt him at all.
And he said, yes sir, we'll take care of that.
And with that we became integrated.
And so now the division integrated.
And by the time we were in the fighting,
we had black company commanders and white battalions,
and so forth.
So we're doing quite well.
When I got back today...
It was military necessity that re-witching.
It was military necessity.
It was the need for bodies.
Yeah, there's so forth in the house.
It was...it had nothing to do with the executive order.
The fact that we were combat, where people qualified,
and the commanders recognized their soldiers,
put them where they needed military necessity.
And that's the way we operated.
By the time I got back to the regiment,
it would have been about...
I guess April, I can check my book for you to find out
what that time was.
And we were in a base area.
The division was still engaged.
I am now a company commander.
Lieutenant, first lieutenant.
And we got a white officer, Captain, assigned to us
to be the company commander.
And he had not been in combat before.
The company had completely integrated by this time.
Then we had low-and-discussive captain myself.
And he said, okay.
I want you to keep doing what you've been doing to be in charge.
I'll take care of the base area and support you.
And that's all I finished to war in Korea.
With that arrangement,
I should point out that by that time I had received two purple hearts.
Receive a silver star for the operations back in the breaking out
of the Poosing perimeter.
I took a Hill 201, I got my first one.
And it's now into May.
Things are going, we're moving gradually ahead.
But by that time they started rotating people home.
And I was able to rotate home.
Leaving the regiment.
Came back to the states.
Went off to, I was assigned to camp Edwards and Massachusetts.
Army is completely integrated now, up to a point.
Up at camp Edwards, they're one black company.
And their job was post police and kitchen work, kitchen,
cooking for the soldiers, small base.
And our job was to police to post police picking up trash and cooking
soldiers for the white soldiers in the white unit.
That unit was all black I might add.
And I did not cut to that very much, but I've been in combat.
I've done a pretty good job, I thought, now I'm back in this kind of situation.
And so I started complaining.
I called my brand, my telephone and say, look, I know what you got got me out here.
I'm still on competitive tour, I understand that too.
And what, don't you think I deserve something better than this?
Within an hour, so I got to call back.
You're being transferred to any town get, any town get military reservations,
which is a basic training for soldiers.
And I went from camp Edwards to any town gap as a company commander, basic training.
It was there that I've been more to captain.
It was there that I got integrated into the regular army.
Orders come in and I'm in tall cotton, happy about that.
Training my unit, we're doing a great job turning out basic trainees.
Also, after industry training soldiers, I was also selected to go to signal of some communication course infantry.
Learn how to become a commo communication officer in an infantry unit.
Why was I selected for that?
Because I had been a signal officer and I said, okay, he can do that.
Big difference between pole climbing and stringing wire and being a guy in charge of communication on the ground.
But I went off to school.
I come back to any town gap after the period of school training, which would about maybe nine weeks.
And was then my family stayed by the way when I was in any town gap.
They stayed in Philadelphia.
And I would go back and forth.
Got orders to Germany.
So just, okay.
We can do that.
Pack up the bags.
We now have two daughters.
I'm not sure did I mention the fact that when my first daughter was born, I'm going back with active duty.
If I didn't mention that, I was heading to Fort Bliss.
And my wife was expecting momentarily.
They put my orders in delay, permitted me to stay in the Philadelphia area.
Well, she delivered, but at that time, they sent me to Fort Momif, which not too far away.
I sent to a signal unit there while we waited.
Our first daughter of born, Shirley.
And then I went to Fort Bliss.
And the family never came down there because it was just right and went right for the family to move and stuff like that.
The second daughter of born when we're hanging off to Korea.
She had born on July.
We took off from the Fort Lewis in July.
She had born September.
And still told my parents relations.
Well, I left the post at Fort Lewis.
We had to stay at the guest house.
And I made arrangements for them to stay there.
And by the time I was heading overseas, my wife had a problem with the manager at the guest house.
One more thing, which you saw a deal with.
While the army, military portion was segregated.
Some of the post facility weren't.
We still have the mentality of our civilians.
And my mother had flown in from Philadelphia to drive my family back to Philadelphia.
My mother was a very interesting person.
She'd go any place, fly, drive, whatever.
And so she drove the car with my wife, her first child.
My company commander and his wife, who was also pregnant,
which may have speak to why my company commander picked me to meet him.
He could trust me.
And our dog.
And they drove back from Fort Lewis to Philadelphia.
Had no problems in route.
They got tremendous treatment.
Went to Columbus, Ohio, where my company commander, wife, was going.
And their child didn't continue to want to fill it.
Excuse me, fill it off you.
My mother got her first treatment speedin' ticket on Pennsylvania Turnbike.
They explained it to who they were.
The center of the trooper was very polite and said, OK, go on, but take it easy.
But my mother wanted, she'd like to drive.
Heavy foot.
And I got to the point that I had to since I was one in charge now.
And she was living in our house.
The next bean ticket you get, that's going to be it.
Because I control the insurance and we can't go through it.
You kill yourself.
But she, OK.
Now I'm hanging off to, I just had to put that in because she was part of the program.
I go off to Germany.
That was probably more scared during that conversation than during some of your combat periods.
Yes.
We're going off to Germany and join the second Army division in West Germany.
Mike Johnson-Hime is our location where my unit was located.
And I was in combat command B, CCB.
I'm now a captain, communication train.
And I became the communication officer for the battalion.
42nd Army and infantry battalion.
And my did a pretty good job.
Learn how to do things with the communication.
I became a Mars military amateur radio.
And I set up the Mars station for the regiment.
And we named it the station after CCB, the regiment.
And the commander of it, I'll be happier because his regiment had a Mars station.
No one else had one.
And so I became a tall cut.
And I got to think that not many of people could have gotten.
And continued training at this time in my Germany.
I now have been over there long enough to come home and doing this training after having my communications training.
I became a company commander, which made it my third company.
And company in combat, even though it was terminated short time, but still did the work.
Company at any time, depth, training company.
And I got another infantry company, armored infantry, and we trained pretty hard.
I had personal carriers as a movement.
Armored plates still for it.
I returned to the States.
It is now 57.
I'd gone to, by the way, back to Fort Benning for Advanced course training before going to Germany.
And I feel to mention that we had our third child there at Fort Benning.
Now, are you seeing racial change in the Army?
The Army is for it.
Yes, it's going through many changes.
And by this time, at Benning, that time, I was completely integrated, integrated unit.
And by the time I got to Germany, totally integrated, integrated, but yet absolutely certain people.
So the signal officer, this senior black officer in the division, was a black lieutenant colonel assigned to our army.
Assigned to our technical service trains, as we call them.
And when it got time for a battalion commander to change, we were encouraging him to become a new battalion commander.
I knew enough people at the division because I had, as a signal officer, I used to, as a communicator, I used to deal with folks at the division.
And when it was an operation, I dealt with the people there.
And I tried to encourage this Lieutenant Colonel to come down and join it because we had fine battalion, and he was qualified.
And the interesting part about his name was Johnson, but his wife was, he may have heard of baseball player Campanillo.
His wife was from that family.
With that name, he could have gotten anything he wanted to, but he decided, no, he would just stay where he is because he accompanied me at Regis here, but the executive officer of a unit, not a combat unit.
And so, he stayed up there, so we did our thing.
It's now time for me to come back to the stage.
I was on ROTC duty, mind you, I did not have a degree.
And I was assigned to a place called Prairie View.
I went, there's a captain, assigned to the military, assigned to the department, the only captain in the unit, a Lieutenant Colonel, three majors, and me, captain.
The junior officer.
A couple of challenges.
When I went to that job, I was sent there by a very good friend who now in the department of Army.
He said, you go down to Prairie View and get your go to school. Take classes, get your degree.
Roger that?
So, when I get, we get to Prairie View, and, on by the way, from racial standpoint, while driving down there,
we were told by some friends from Germany.
Now, when you go down, you stop by white friends, when you go to Mississippi, stop by this place.
My parents are there, see them, and they'll take care of you.
Try me through.
Now, make sure you don't talk to two people.
One is the mother, they talk to my father, they don't talk to my mother, and he'll understand.
Don't talk to her, she won't understand, because I'm still blind, and they still haven't gotten to that point.
I might add also, going there, that while we're in Germany, I keep forgetting these things now.
While in Germany, my mother and mother-law joined us.
They came over to visit with us to see Europe, trip over there, and we convinced my wife's mother to stay with us.
My father finally got tired. He said, when are you coming home, Rose Bechton?
And she got the message, so she got home and came back.
She had a good time, mom had a good time, stay with us.
And that made a family comfortable, because my mother-law with us took everything, and she stayed with us until she died.
And I might also add that while she was with us, whenever there was a disagreement in my family, in myself, my mom was on my side, which irritated Louise, no in.
That's no story.
Why did at time we get to Texas, per review, with three daughters, the third one was born while at Fort Benning,
and she's from her background, per certificate, Reese Georgia.
And it was also in Columbus, Georgia, that my wife learned how to drive and get driver's license,
and the policeman who checked her out for driving.
He got into the car, and Louise got on the driver's side, and he said, okay, told her to do certain things.
And she drove probably less than a block, turned around because the police over the door, parked the car, got out, you passed.
And I later found out that the officer was so impressed by the way that she controlled herself, the way she got into the car, where she adjusted everything, and how she made the U-turn and parked the car, that's enough for him.
That was her driver's license.
Okay, we're now at Fort down at per review.
We got a house ridden from an old map professor who had a second house.
My professor, Military Science, my boss, was Lieutenant Colonel.
I said we got three majors and myself, and I had my instructor, my group, what the teaching of juniors.
Military Science 3 is the specification.
There are no white students, a few white faculty, and I was the only combat experienced officer in this group.
I mean, late war, we had something reward too.
And when I announced to Professor Military Science, I'm going to take courses, and he blew up.
There's no way in the world you can take a course that worked for me.
Sir, I was sent down here. You're assigned here, right? Yes, sir. You can't take courses.
In work as a student, I should also point out that in this building, I was also his assistant.
We went to my office, right outside the office, we're just located.
The next day, after we had this little blow up, I reported in about 7.30, the Colonel comes in about 30 minutes later.
I told him this door, which is not, which is usual.
In a few minutes, I get a call. Back then, get in here. Yes, sir.
I go in his office, report it. All right. He even took the courses.
But let me tell you one thing. If there's any indication whatsoever, is interfering with your being an instructor, you're in trouble.
Yes, sir. I understand that. No question about kosher. I came back outside, and my couple of sergeants, they knew what was going on.
They smiled. Two or three majors were roaming back and forth. They got worried that the doctor could take courses now.
The third major was the exec that he had his own office. I'm pointing out he's out to present the climate.
I am now a regular Army captain, the only regular Army officer in the group, the only non-collect graduate, the only one had been combat recently.
Now, I got my way by going to taking courses. I'm a target for a lot of people to shoot at.
But I was pretty good at what I did. I did a good instructor, and I did well academically.
I should point out that I develop a relationship with the students that even to this day, we're still very close to each other.
I am now a processing graduation, been there for two years. The last year I'm there, the Army pays for my going to school.
They had a final semester plan. When you get within your final semester graduation, the Army footed the bill for books and everything.
That took no worries from that standpoint. I was able to do my job being a instructor, able to get what the doing classes quite well.
I was able to influence the Professor Military Science. A new one came in by that time.
He understood what I was doing. He was then a colonel who came in to become the Professor Military Science.
He was able to influence the person coming in to be the commencement speaker who I had met back when I was in Washington.
We're now 1960. Time for a commencement. Receive my degree. The commencement speaker makes some reference to Captain Bechton.
It's such a good man, great reputation. This did not hurt him with reputation in the schools.
My fellow students smile and the professors smile and stuff like that. When I crossed the stage to get my diploma degree, the person reading off the graduate, listed graduate, stopped the movement.
Wait a minute. Captain Bechton is a 5,000 graduate of Per View A&M University. Now the chance of my being a 5,000 graduate like a snowball in the hill. I don't believe it.
But the 5,000 graduate played during that period and it's convenient for the Army and for the university to use that opportunity.
I walked off the 5,000 graduate that smiling and got my degree, we're in Torcontan.
Okay. I now have a diploma, went back into the Army,
went off to the Command General Staff College.
They school for particularly selected young captains and majors, and Lieutenant Crownfoot, particularly young captains.
I'm now a regular Army officer in the school at Command General Staff College at Fort Leb Worry.
And peers support. Could not ask for more because I met people in Germany at any town gap in elsewhere.
My student company commander at the Fort Benning who was a Lieutenant Colonel, he maintained relationships with me.
He later became a division commander, which is rather important.
I'm now at Fort Leb Worry, tough academic work, working very hard to get through.
While there I become a major.
The Army is still not that overrun by black officer, but in my class at Leb Worry, we had 16 black officers out of 600.
And we sort of kept together as a group, except for one. He was Lieutenant Colonel.
He felt that he was above him, dignity, dignity, to associate with major's junior to him.
So to make a long story short, we got through, he failed academically. The rest of us made it.
We studied for exams, and he reviewed the joint for studying. And we went through. We worked together.
We're together. From Leb Worry, it is now in the 62, graduate in 61.
Kennedy has become the president. Had to little freak us down in Mexico, Cuban, whatever you want to call it.
And they started their little mess around in Germany. And before we left Leb Worry, we had orders to France.
Of that group that went to France, six of us went to the communications zone in France out of class, which is, for come out of our officers, not all that good, we thought.
And we started, why us? Why aren't we going to Germany to become, you know, where the real Army is, not technicians, logisticians, stuff like that?
I found I got the message someone else got it, that the commander in the communications zone, France had complained about not getting his fair share of talent.
And of the six of us going into France, two of us were black, one was just Lieutenant Colonel who failed at Leb Worry.
And I ended up in the same unit that he was, which a very interesting story, no, the story. He finally decided to talk.
And I got a pretty good job. He went to logistic G4. And I was in operations, G3 became eventually a chief of plants and operations.
In France, my job was to prepare for the evacuation of US forces, families from Germany after passing through with me at the Russians across the border, or each German across the border.
We get them out back to the stage. And I got pretty good at doing that too, I might add.
In the meantime, this Lieutenant Colonel who failed Leb Worry, he sort of gotten more troubles in his job. But I just ignore him.
His wife was livid because we were doing so well, family doing so well with, and we had our foreg, and we had a foreg, and we had a foreg, now at Leb, at Prairie View, our fourth daughter was born.
And I might ask, I keep forgetting to say, my wife doing that period, she worked to get her degree and became a staff nurse in the college nursing.
And we did such a great job so that when the dean left, my wife was asked to be the acting dean for the period where the dean was not getting her doctoral study complete.
So you got this young R N B S who had did so well that the president of college said, okay, you be the acting dean.
That did not make the other nurses very comfortable who bid her for some time, but they respected her.
And I'm making a point of this because that's so my fourth daughter was born. I took time to do that. And she had developed a relationship with the doctor so that he suggested she go to Himstead, which is nearby town rather than having the birth at the university.
So she delivered there. They very first mailed us, see her, what the professor military scientist, knew Colonel, he came in.
And as I said, he was a great guy. He was the air force. When I was on the campus working in also in class, he later became her godfather.
I might add that this daughter went on to become a Colonel Air Force. And she's now Colonel Air Force retired. So time that goes on.
Okay.
Let me ask you one question or a couple of questions.
Sure.
During this period, were you keeping track of, I mean, you're in a military world in some ways, but there's the wider world as well.
There's a lot of change going on. So there are in, especially in terms of race issues and with the Montgomery bus.
All those change came up and we were a C. Keelya were of it. And many of I and my peers.
Like we decide we just like we're demonstrating how good we can be doing our job in the Army.
We don't have to get out there and parade with placard or join any setting and stuff like that.
So we think we're doing a better job helping race relations by proving that we can make it.
And that's was our relationship with the public and with peers who are no longer in the military. And they understood.
And when I later became a president of a unit president of Pervy A&M University.
And that's, of course, in K-MOT. What were you doing during the war?
Fighting protecting you. That's what I'm doing. And they understood that too. And it helped.
We saw we have friends who. Not military who were involved.
For turning. He's gotten involved. My wife was sorority and academic sorority I might add.
Her group did things for the.
Seterans and for other people. But did they get involved in those kind of thing? No.
Where it came home to haunt us, I might add.
Was when my daughter Karen.
Who went to second daughter born and she went off to South Dakota.
Don't ask me how she got to South Dakota but I still don't know.
She heard that good schools and a couple of her friends suggested she go there. So she went there.
And.
This took place when I was in Korea. And when.
I heard that she was gotten free.
Good student. Her participation was writing letters for the local newspapers.
Campus newspapers. Anti-war.
Articles. And when I heard that, of course, you knew I blew up.
Remind her where she's from, what she did. I never once see an article written by you about anti-military.
She stopped writing. Naturally she stopped writing but we were paying the bill for her going to school.
That was one thing.
We had there are marches.
We did not participate. We understood what they're doing.
And we maintained by doing our job in military to the best of our ability.
Help the overall. Opportunity what they're trying to do.
I still believe that today.
Was there some pride in the fact that the military had pioneered in integration.
Even though it was bumpy, of course, but they did.
It was realized by a lot of people, certainly not in the military, what did the public do?
That the integration in the military, it would black majors, black students,
academicians were doing on a college campus.
And in the military itself, we're making things happen, good things happen because.
With a Tuskegee Airman, proving that they could do that, what they're doing.
We had senior officers were able to get things done.
And it wasn't too long thereafter because I became a major general.
I mean, a Brigadier General, Colonel First and Brigadier General.
And I had command and.
Our first command was at Fort Hood as a brigade commander.
Colonel in the same unit that was a communication officer for back in Germany.
Excuse me.
The same relationship I made in Germany I was still continued.
And again, how in the military back at Levent worth and for our left Levent worth in France.
In the military, we float around.
We eat each other and things.
We get to know each other.
And I said, in France, I was able to help to develop a relationship.
I did my job very well.
The Lieutenant Colonel then Colonel of the unit I was in in France became a Colonel.
And later Brigadier General.
And we still maintain relationship even though I was there.
But that time a major Lieutenant Colonel, he just a good guy.
He was able to help me to get some things done later.
He spoke up for me on certain occasions.
And it helped.
And my peers, black peers, were able to get the same thing.
We knew what we had to do.
We had our job prepared for it.
And we advanced in the ranks.
And we're respected for what we did.
We got to certain schools because of what we've done.
Not because we're black but because we're good at what we did.
And to this day, I have a relationship with people.
That call I just had, I'm going to return.
This is a Colonel who was tired from the Army.
He is now a civilian in the Department of Army.
They call them SCSRs these days.
A senior person working in personnel.
He's going to tell me something.
What's taking place in the Army today.
He understands what I've been doing, what I have done.
And going ahead a little bit, I have been asked to do certain things.
What a Congress.
Several years ago, the Congress set up a commission for diversity in the military,
military leadership diversity.
The Chairman of that commission was a general, forced-ar, less-loules.
I would, the Vice Chairman, the Senate General.
And we prepared this study for the Army, for the military to deal with diversity.
Now, is that racial relations?
Not really.
It's diversity because there's a big difference.
And to some of our people, military, and civilians,
we're unable to understand that difference.
A firmative action had certain gateposts.
It's so many, they had a form of it.
How many folk can you have or what should they be doing?
Diversity is not so much how many blocks you would have,
but what are you doing for the total population to demonstrate that we're all qualified.
And diversity is a function of learning from each other.
And a lot of folk never got that message, even to this day.
And so, I've had chance to work at those levels.
What do you think of these, I mean, we've seen some tremendous changes recently
in the combat positions for women being totally open?
I'm smallly in the code.
It was our commission, military leadership, diversity commission that made that came down very hard,
get rid of the restriction for women.
If they're qualified, put them in a job.
And we saw it.
It went so far as to what just happened with the Secretary of Defense.
But we had, when women went to Ranger School, I could not have been happier.
Even in this building, we're a little bit about it.
We got some very senior officers here who think they know what's going on.
And they blew up, and I blew up too.
In this very room, we had a meeting one day, Rotary had a meeting.
And I'm not a Rotaryian, but I announced the fact that of the bringing in military,
the military and the army, but putting them in a qualified.
Women had just been integrated into the Ranger School.
And I could not have been happier.
And I was singing the next room for dinner, which are Rotaryian.
They got a telephone call from my son, who I forgot to mention when he was born.
But he was a captain in the old guard in Washington as a company commander,
on a guard company commander.
And he resigned his commission because he would never convince them when he got his own.
His name is Julius Wesley Bechton III.
And every time he went in, he placed Bechton.
I know your father. How are he doing?
He can take that from someone.
And he finally got fed up with it.
He wanted to make his own.
Let me break for one story.
He was a company commander, captain at the Pentagon.
No. At the Pentagon preparing the ground for a parade for the honor guard,
the whole guard that was for the military.
He was out preparing the ground, putting in flags, markers.
And two senior officers come out.
One, a fellow named Gordon Sullivan, chief of staff of the Army.
A fellow named Colin Powell, chairman of the joint chief of staff.
And they see Wes. He comes up to it.
Wes, how you doing? Find, sir.
How's your father? Find, sir.
What's your mother doing? Sir, she's...
They kept on with this crap.
He found these. Sir, I got to go to work.
Okay. They go all this time.
His car was over. Glaring at him.
But he stuck with these four stars.
That's the kind of relationship that we've had over the years.
And we still got that relationship to this day.
But, um...
Okay. Where am I now?
I was...
I had been... We had been talking about the change in the...
the diversity of commission and...
The former guy in the school.
And women...
Women and the...
The rangers.
Yeah, well that...
But that has worked very well.
I think the proof of it, those two women got through the Ranger School.
And the interesting part about that.
One of our senior...
One of our... Not senior.
There were one, two, three, four lieutenant generals in this place.
One senior to me, older than I am by...
A couple of years.
He was sitting at this dinner table when I...
Sitting there, my son called me and said,
He's a Ranger too, my son.
Hey, they just got through.
And I walked back in, just smiling and said,
I just got the best news you can think of.
My son called me and said,
Those two rangers, female, just got through.
And there were maybe 15 of us, 20...
Except for this colonel.
Ha!
Enough for much of what's up.
West being lesbian.
And I blew up.
I went one on a table, he's the other end.
And how, when the hell can you say that?
They're qualified, they've proved it.
And these civilians say,
I mean civilians, they're these non-army type...
They're listening to this.
And right now we're at the point we may speak to each other.
But I made a point to prove...
I got a piece of paper that said,
Not only were they qualified, they're proving that they're metastandards.
They're doing a job.
And he now...
And my wife, a cute, being...
In a probic, I just refused to talk to him,
Except to say hello.
Until he apologized, something else.
But anyhow, they're qualified.
And that's what we're expecting.
That's what we want them to do.
And so to answer your question, yes, I've faced that.
Here we have it.
There are 580 people here.
One, two, three black American families.
Two and two, three wives, spouses who are here,
Spouses male or deceased.
Yellow family.
Leo Brooks.
The name may not be anything to you,
But his son just got promoted to four stars.
A year and a half ago.
And he had to do it so pretty well.
Leo, the father, is retired.
Brigadier.
His other son is a retired two star, one star.
And so they got two sons, one Brigadier, one four stars.
And they all talk about their two sons and what they're doing.
And other people talk about that too.
And I get irritated.
Wait a minute, hold it.
They got a daughter.
And she's my lawyer.
She's better qualified than they are.
Okay, so we have an understanding.
If you're going to talk about the Brooks,
you better talk about Marquita.
She is our lawyer and she's doing a fine thing.
Terrific.
And so she's a big law farm downtown.
And so, but we have that kind of relationship here.
Interesting enough, I've been here since, oh wait, as I said,
Leo came in two years later.
And, amusingly so, he got here because Louise had a luncheon for some general officer wives here,
Black and that luncheon rotate around.
And Naomi, who was Leo's wife, was in the group.
The person in charge of apartments and running and getting folks in
was invited to a luncheon to talk about opportunities that come into the fair fight.
And she did a great job.
Naomi goes home that night and said, Leo, we're moving.
We're what?
Leo, we're moving.
I just sort of play.
We're not moving.
We can't afford to move.
Did you hear what I said, Leo?
We are moving.
And so, we've known the Brooks for a long time.
Ever since Leo come, every time he thinks about it, I hate you.
I talk to my wife and her friend.
She smiles.
That's funny.
You may see him going by in a wheelchair, connecting a brace.
That is a Air Force, Brigadier,
injured, severely injured,
and is, well, that's a kind of folks we have here.
But anyhow, the Brooks are good friends.
And there's Sunnett just doing a superb job.
He's a commander of the Pacific.
You can't get much bigger than that.
And I'm so happy about it because I've known him since he was a teenager.
As I've done the daughter who was also 18, we first met him at Fort Dillard.
And he's just, every time something happens good, I feel great.
So there's a real fraternity among siblings.
Oh, it was still a question about that.
As a matter of fact, when I, when Vince got his promotion to four stars,
I had a four star brace, Penn, given to me by a former boss,
who gave it to me after I got put with the three stars.
And he said, I missed all your promotion.
I'm going to have me there ahead of time.
Penn is on when you get promoted.
Well, that's not going to happen.
I kept it when Vince got promoted to four stars.
He penned on my four stars I gave him.
That kind of relationship we have.
We have fun.
It's terrific.
And I'm trying to figure out where I left off that.
And Germany, thank you.
So we've gotten up to about 61.
Okay.
Good.
Yeah.
I went to France, came back from France in 63.
I was in France.
We were in France.
We were done in France when Kennedy got shot.
And we listened to the old radio.
And stuff with you, American people don't realize that when that happened to our president,
every radio station in France start playing.
And we were playing music that was appropriate for our debt back here, for our leader.
And you could not have asked for it.
Be more proud of what.
For us, of what they did for us.
Okay.
I get back from.
France.
Go off to the Armed Forces staff college.
Down in.
Norfolk.
Or, you know, Northfolk, Virginia.
Armed forces all schools, all services.
This was, lab work, but primarily Army, but other services were there.
Armed Forces staff colleges teach about each other's services and become joint staff officers.
Okay.
There, the daughter that was born and fort mening, living on the post on the Fort Staff College,
the military, you to school and local community.
And we had the only black at the Armed Forces staff college.
So when our daughter in the third grade,
riding the bus from the school, that school would just integrate it.
So she became the first black to go to that school as a student.
She was met at the door when the bus pulled up by the principal.
And he got her off the bus and scored her into the class.
And the teacher was told who's coming in.
And he made sure she got back on the bus.
No problems.
And that's the way her class went.
She was a great student.
She did very, very well.
She moved from, in the first semester,
from being at a third grade, she moved to advanced to a fourth grade.
Because of what she'd been doing before that.
And she could take to have this escort by the minutes by the principal.
It got to the point where we got out of that environment back in the Washington.
She felt so pretty good by herself.
She had a principal taking her part.
I'm now in Washington assigned to desperate the office for personnel.
The same office as Colonel, this Colonel will be talking to later.
My first job was dealing with National Guard and reserve of affairs by the Army.
And it was during that period that the Alabama battle took place.
Going to the bridge and to riot.
Rosalpar.
The Army Operation Center was made up of not assigned persons,
most of us came from volunteer, volunteer people,
elsewhere, pulled together, and worked.
My job was to contact the National Guard Commander on the ground
and maintain communication for him with him for the Army staff.
The very first night out, the chief of staff wanted to find out,
okay, where were the marchers and what the Army doing protecting the Army?
What are their deployment?
And the general who represented us with the chief of staff had no idea nor at all.
But I'm the guy sitting in the operations center.
Find out. Got that?
You know, I call off this Army Commander National Guard.
He's probably the Brigadier General.
I told who it was.
I'm now a Lieutenant Colonel.
I said, this is what we need to know.
What is the location of your crew served weapons?
What is the location of the other people?
We need to report the chief of staff.
What the hell do you folks need that for?
I said, Colonel, I mean General, I'm only calling the chief of staff and the Army
wants to find out.
I'd be happy to tell him that you refused to give it to me.
No, I'll tell you.
So he gave me a look at the crew served weapons.
I report that back to the my boss.
General, he went up and reported the chief of staff.
We're talking, it's still sensitive to race because I was about it.
My job was to make sure we knew where they were and how they got there.
I then went back to my job as a guy in charge of race of guard and reservists
on the Army staff.
During the meantime, the Army Comptroller Colonel was a
hair force, I mean Colonel from West Point.
He was the Colonel who taught me, he always told me how to shoot crap as I take a
mission to you going over.
He is now a Colonel and now I'm a, you know, this time I was a Colonel.
And we got together quite often and he laughed about it, taking my money and I'm laughing
about that too because I'm now hiring you.
I'm not small about that.
I'm back in the Pentagon, Pentagon, as a Lieutenant Colonel working hard.
I went from there to a graduate program that the Department of Defense
had started for systems analysts.
And that's when they had McNamara WizKids and they were creating problems for the Army.
And the Army, the military set up a small group of qualified systems analysts.
I was selected to go along with five Army officers to this class of some 31-32 people
offered IDA, it's two for defense analysis, they ran a program.
I was a senior officer and so all that meant that I was, I spoke for the Army for the military
in his class when it was necessary.
I'm small because in sending up this group, I got over to this as a student because I had
many math major at Prairie View even though I did not do well in analytical geometry years
ago.
And economics is a function of math in many respects and so I have my math background.
I got selected to go to school, went off to school, full-time, graduate school, run by the
University of Maryland this program.
I finished there, here later came back to the Army staff, it was assigned to the Office
of Assistant Secretary, Assistant Chief of Staff of the Army.
A group set up to, as some people said, rewrite what the staff said because our hires didn't
like what we were giving them so they rewrote themselves.
I meant that we were required before I got to them to make sure it fit the categories
they needed.
My biggest problem was a particular general who widow is here and we see her every once
a while and she's a best friend but I said you know what your husband did to me but they
held another story.
We worked at that staff, that route until it's time to go to Ford Hood as a colonel brigade
commander which is something we a lot of folks look forward to doing.
Let me back up from that.
Before doing that, after leaving this graduate program I got selected for a National War
College, senior service college, the highest schools for any soldiers, Army, Navy, Marines,
all have their own schools except the National War College is all of them together.
I went off to that school and was the third black American Army to go to National War
College.
The first to go there at that time was a Roscoe Robinson who was the first to go from
Westporder to get the four stars.
His wife is here, she is a sad to say suffering from dementia and does not recognize anyone.
While I was at the National War College he went off to Hawaii and he sent back and said hey can you send me a sweat
suit because my wife put a sweat suit in and bleach it and I can't recognize it.
So I went off board one and said what?
Well now at the National War College, again academically is a great school.
I enjoyed it, knit well.
I went from National War College.
Now what's happening in Southeast Asia at this point?
What year are we in?
We're now 61.
I graduated 61 from National War College.
So whatever happened then we got folks over there.
I'm not too sure back 61.
I was not involved and so I got to do other things.
But when I left the National War College I went to Ford Hood as a brigade commander.
I think I mentioned that and we trained for very hard.
And I enjoyed what I was doing.
I had a good staff and good troops.
Came over to Chief of Staff's office.
I left there as Lieutenant Colonel rather important period because I went out to Campbell as a squadron commander in the 101st Airborne Division.
Which is the, there are two Airborne Division, 82nd in the 101st.
And we have to think that 101st is the best of them.
And on top of that I was a Lieutenant Colonel, armor leaving the National War College going off to command a squadron.
And the, there was only one Cav Squadron into the division.
And only two Cav Squadrons like that in the Army, one 82nd the other 101st.
And now it's time to, and we train very well, very hard.
Now I'm not, I will not Airborne qualified.
I got Airborne qualified when I left the, on a Forces staff car I went to jump school and qualified as a paratrooper.
You remember I said when I'm gonna pull, I don't like heights.
Why don't you jump out of airplane?
He's a challenge, that's what I did.
So you were continually training even through all these.
That's right.
Hey, that's what we're all about.
But I'm now Airborne qualified.
I'm gonna command a armor unit, I spent most of my time as infantry, except with the second Army Division.
I was an armored infantry, but not an armored unit as such.
Never command a tank unit.
Never even fired a tank gun.
But I go off to the 101st Airborne Division.
We train hard, Vietnam.
I am the only black commander in the division at that level.
And all of the battalion commanders, we have one black Colonel, and he commanded the trains, logistics.
We're off to Vietnam that very well.
Battalion squadron commander for the first part of my tour.
And then the last part of my tour was Deputy Brigade Commander.
And I had chance to meet some very important people as a squadron commander.
During the war, I got visited by fellow named Crete Neighbors.
Military assistant commander, McVeigh and Vietnam.
I was the only armor unit in his area, in that area.
And when he came out, he came to visit me.
He landed his chopper, get out, salute him, come over, sit on the Jeep.
Okay, Joyce, what have you done now?
I'm talking to him about what we're doing, how well we're doing and so forth.
Got a great relationship, which proved to be very important later on.
Fort the war, we got a couple of citations, medals and stuff like that.
Came back to the States, assigned to the Army staff again,
as a colonel.
I get promoted to Brigadier General and assigned to Fort Dix New Jersey.
Now an interesting part about that, Fort Dix is not too far from Philadelphia.
I'm now the deputy commander of Fort Dix.
My job is to really be the guidance charge of training the post commanders
and job to everything else.
And we worked very hard, drill sergeant worked for me.
And I had a superb boss.
Early on, he sent me to Washington to convince the Army not to close Fort Dix.
He was doing a phase down.
And the folks in the Army determined to close it.
And our article was, this is the major training center in the whole North-Eastern Puerto Rican
United States.
For a paracendera, youngsters to go in the Army and train there.
Now you're going to close it.
And I had beat up by Felonet Rizzo from Philadelphia, mayor.
He went on to tell the Fort they can't close it because we needed.
All the time, my civilians who live working for Dix.
What are you going to do if you close it?
I'm a Brigadier, I'm not a Colonel, Brigadier John, rather.
And I go to Washington and try to explain.
And back to, we hear what you're saying.
Now go back and go do your job.
Yes, sir.
Go back to Fort Dix.
I tell my boss, Bert David.
He tell her, when else that?
So what do they do?
They turn the politicians loose.
And guess what?
Fort Dix is still open today.
Is it not?
When the politicians get involved, sometimes good things happen.
Train is no longer there, but Fort Dix is still open.
Anyhow, Fort Dix, I'm Deputy Commander.
We worked very hard.
I, boss, Bert David, get transferred to Washington to logistics.
His replacement comes in.
He's a guy who got promoted to Brigadier General St.
I did.
But in the meantime, he got promoted to two stars.
Now he's my boss.
I've been there about a year when he got there.
So I know most of the people, everybody.
And everybody knows me.
And he's incoming.
So when, although he's the commander, and I'm still a deputy,
when things happen, who would he come see?
I'm just stuck in.
Okay.
Fine.
I understand that.
Time moves on for, he's been there for about six months.
And the two star list comes out, Major General,
and I get forward to the Major General.
No.
He doesn't fuss about that, but he says, okay, I get rid of him now.
Because the job I'm feeling is that of a Brigadier,
not of a two star.
I'm still there, and no one tell me where I'm going to go.
I stay at Fort Dix for about six months as a two star,
and he's a two star.
A little bit discomfort on his part.
Because he want to be the sole guy in charge.
I'm not trying to fuss him or cause a problem.
But when people come in, I get to be the guy.
His two son guy, the problem one day,
the pro-war's come see me.
Go see me, go see him.
His son's not mine.
No, but okay.
I now get orders.
I get to be with the two stars in August.
And I'm still setting a Fort Dix.
And I went for about three months before I find out what I'm going to do.
I find out I'm going to go to Fort Hood
as a division commander.
Now, why am I shocked by that?
I'm going to command an armored division.
And I'm also going to go when you got a little two star.
What that job?
Because this armored division is being converted
from a triple capability division to a fewer armored division.
My armored experience is not very much.
My boss at Fort Dix wanted a division.
He got training center.
Big difference between those two.
Two star billet, but I'm going to a division and he is stuck there.
And so, okay.
I find out, and the final analysis,
that Kraven Abrams, the fellow I said,
came out to visit the North War four star at DCs.
And he has written notes,
Beckton gets the armored division, first calf.
And it went into the record that way.
And so now, I'm heading off to Fort Hood to command a division.
However, when I leaving Fort Dix,
my boss wrote the worst report card ever gotten, OER.
Beckton is great at dealing with the civilians,
great at dealing with community affairs,
great at dealing with other things.
He is horrible in training.
No training discipline whatsoever.
I've already left the training.
I've been...
Okay, I'm down at Fort Hood,
going to command a division.
And this report card goes up the chain.
And when I get to Fort Hood,
I've been in command a division maybe two weeks.
And by the way, I'm the only two black division commanders at that time.
And we communicate with each other.
Harry Brooks, who was out in Hawaii,
25th division, and I got the first kind of division.
The...
I had three superb battalion commanders,
I'm Brigade Commanders.
My chief of staff of the division
happened to be also a resident here today.
I never knew the guy before, but he did a fine job.
And I was happy with him.
And he'd now forced our might at how he got there.
It's an old story.
But we have a great time around here.
I get the at Hood.
We did a lot of hard training.
It's been a lot of time in the field.
Trying some new concepts.
Work, the work, the work.
It has time now been there for about two years.
The Ray Freylation is doing that here.
We're talking in a community as...
Took a man in 76 of the division.
And 78...
Well, let me back up a little bit.
Early 76.
Yeah, 76, early 76, January.
And it's...
A wife's having a good time.
The family's having a good time.
The fourth child has been born, I mean, the fifth child, the son, the one I mentioned.
He is on act of duty.
Everything is right with the world.
It's time for me to be transferred.
And I lived next door to the Corps Commander.
He calls me up, said, on an interesting story.
When I took Command and Division, I replaced the guy who became the Corps Commander.
But we knew each other as Brigadiers.
He's a good guy.
And as we prepare for my taking Command and Division, he said, okay, when you get here,
George, we're going to have a...
Change the Command, mount it, mount it, change the Command, and...
We're going to troop the line, mount it, and then you take Command.
Bob, his name.
Hey, look, my experience riding a horse is not all that great.
And I've been trained here at For Hood, how to ride a horse, because you know your wife taught me how to do that.
She's a great horseman.
And why don't you march on horse and I stand and stand, and then nomenchart and go to a late.
Armored Division. Armored Division, don't ride horses.
Okay, now we'll do it that way.
And then before I get there, I get where who could be my boss.
He could be my boss.
He's calling up again.
Guess what? I guess I should tell you, I'm going to be the core commander.
And on the subject of Change the Command, this is how we're going to do it.
And you see a book in the picture on the back of a horse, and we're going to get them to ground stuff like that.
But we go through this.
I survived it.
Yeah.
I move from that division to a place in the spring outside in Billy's Crossroads.
O.T.A., Army Operations on Test and Evaluation Agency.
Our job in the test, all Army equipment and concepts in the hands of soldiers, what happens when soldiers put their hands on it.
Does it still work?
Of course, there's no one else looked like me in that job.
I have close ties with my counterpart in the Air Force and the Marine Corps.
Each of them have such a unit.
My technician, a civilian, a real engineer, walked college.
When I get there, he's been there forever.
And when I walk in, he said, congratulations, General.
Glad to have you here.
Maybe we talk.
Sure.
Okay.
I'll support you anywhere I can.
One thing I expect.
If I make a decision, I make a recommendation, and go before the Congress, and you change that, don't expect me to not tell them what I think.
What I understand that, I'm not going to make any decision that you don't agree with.
It's okay, fine.
And that's the relationship we had.
We tested the M1 tank.
The new tank, not new.
It was new then.
Abram's tank.
It's that unit.
The program manager for that tank is also resident here.
This is quite a collection of people.
He takes great, you'd like, you tell them people, how high I haven't do this.
We've got a good tank out, didn't we?
Okay.
Now let's start by now.
I'm at that unit doing very well.
It's now 77.
Going into 78.
I get orders.
Any promotion to three stars.
Then.
I get invited to.
Invited.
I told him to come over to the Chief of Staff.
We had a long conversation.
Did not know.
What the job could be.
But I told him you get posed with three star, but there are a couple of buildings I could go to.
And I end up getting the largest combat corps in the Army.
Combat corps in the Army.
In your seven corps.
Hard job was to be technically into Russia's cross the border.
And hell, I'm just as happy as I could be.
Ready to go.
From a racial standpoint.
There are no other black corps commanders.
The announcement of might be in the core of that corps command was held up.
And extra several months.
Well, the.
Army.
Told a year's for a commander who then told a German.
That a lieutenant general Bechtin is coming in as command in a seven corps.
And a white away he's a black American to see how they took to it.
Then follow them.
And so that's what's done.
I get over there.
And oh, I go.
No, I think you found him using.
While I'm getting ready to go to Germany, you're required to go to language school if you're going to go to language you don't speak.
And while I'm in my language training in German, what delayed because they didn't want to make the announcement.
I'm going to be the core commander to German corps commander until.
I can get the language in.
And I couldn't do that until I went to school.
And so.
While I'm in school, I am learning how to speak German.
I spent my entire time, most of my time preparing my remarks.
Right.
Or when I get there because you had to go through that.
And I had German in Muleenburg.
Matter of fact, I became a president of German American club because I was doing so well in German.
And as I've prepared my remarks going from English to German to English to German.
And by the time I got to Germany, I had that downpacked.
At the change of command, I was on a platform.
I was on a press, German public, public soldiers out in the field in front of me.
And I went to that spiel about using George and English going from English to George back in four for about 15 minutes.
And when I finish, I'm so proud of myself.
I got off the platform, parades over.
I'm being sent up on by the press.
Guess what you're speaking.
You know, I speak English.
I'm just speaking German.
And I'm prepared for my remarks, prepared.
And I loved it big time.
And of course, I made it very clear.
And they understood what I was faced with, what I had done.
And I made it very clear.
Whenever I went to talk to any group in the future, I never attempted to speak German.
Because I could make it, I could say, good and talk and all of it was in and stuff like that, but no conversation.
Well, once it took command of the Corps, we had three great divisions.
One commanded by a guy who was a very good friend of mine who had been on my, who had been classmates together.
He wanted the division commanders.
He retired as a four-star might add.
The other was a very good friend.
Infantry.
He was a third-infantry division.
And I had a division back here in the first infantry division out in Colorado.
But they would join us if we were broke out.
So I had two divisions.
An armored cab unit, a counter unit to do.
I'll redo the covering force and doing the thing what Calvary normally does.
And as I joined this Corps, the deputy, my deputy is phoning George Patton.
George and I had a great relationship, an interesting relationship.
Back when I was in Vietnam,
George had a regiment and I had a squadron.
But he had a different area.
And when Abram came out and see me, he irritated George.
No wind because I'm getting all the attention.
Okay, George moves up.
He gets more to Brigadier General.
And he goes off to Fort Knox and becomes the assistant combatant.
In the meantime, I become the branch chief while he's there.
When I left the brigade, he went back to Washington.
I became armored branch chief and charged an assignment of all armor officers.
That's shocked people too.
I never been to Fort Knox as a school.
I never had a great deal of experience deal with assignments.
I did have the support of the guy who sent me there from Fort Hood.
And I had the support of the staff in the Pentagon.
And it became branch chief and it irritated George Patton no wind.
Because he's sending up there for Fort Knox.
In charge of all armor officers school, I'm in charge of assignments.
And normally the branch chief gets invited to the branch school to talk to the students.
Patton, hell no.
Damn, not an armor graduate, not an armored unit.
Why should I invite a him here?
Okay, George, that's your business, sir.
Some fine.
I'm happy with that.
I now go to Fort Hood as a division commander.
And he comes in command of a second armored division.
We could get along well together.
And I had done my job, he'd done his job.
And I go from there to the ICAP to the OTA, training, testing unit.
George goes to Germany and becomes the deputy commander, seven corps.
Time moves on.
I come in as his new commander.
George comes in, boss, glad you're here.
You're in any way I can.
You tell me do something, I'll do it.
George, you're the only thing I'm gonna tell you.
Do your job.
You know what it is, you've been here.
I have not been here before.
You understand what's to be done?
Got it.
And we worked together quite well.
He never said, sir, one time.
Boss, always.
Okay.
This is now October, November, December.
George comes in and boss.
I like the way he doing things.
I like to send my family home.
Okay.
Fine.
In the meantime,
I'll write before that.
He said, I like to be transferred back to, no, no.
Yeah.
He said, I like to, I think I'll transfer back to the states.
If that's okay with you, I call my boss at Heidelberg,
United States Army, Europe Commander,
the same fellow who was a student company commander
when I was at Fort Benning, Blanchard,
and the same guy who made 80 Second Airborne Division
when I was getting started with the first calf.
And he's now the four star in charge of Europe.
Sir, George wants to go home good.
Okay.
I'll go back and tell Patent, the boss said, okay.
Fine.
And then we have an exercise, Reforger.
Return of forces to Germany, which is next exercise,
proving that we can move forces from,
cutting their limbs to the United States to Germany,
fall under a pre-presisting equipment, and fight the war.
That's George's big in charge of lacking seven core equipment.
There's a Reforger exercise,
and now we're going to have field operations.
Reforger come in from Colorado.
George's in charge of core rear
and some other administrative things.
And the equipment that they're incoming through fall and known.
And I'm out fighting the training battle.
We get along superbly well.
However, one minor thing.
This is being done in February.
This exercise.
George's family is back in the States.
And the weather turned like it is today.
No frozen ground.
This is unusual for us.
This weather is unusual for us in Germany back in those days.
And the weather turned warm.
And I got hundreds of tanks out in the field tearing up German property.
And we just got to stop this.
So we're going to cancel.
We're going to terminate.
And I checked that with my boss.
He agreed.
And I was okay.
I will announce the fight we're going to terminate.
And lunch and said,
no, I'm the user commander.
I will take care of that.
And all of a sudden,
I'm following Al Hague flies in.
You may remember I mentioned Hague,
once you graduate my high school.
He flies in and lands.
I guess I'll make the announcement then.
It's not back to the core commander.
It's not the four-store user commander.
But the Supreme Allied Commander,
you're going to make this announcement.
Okay.
In a meantime,
we're out talking while the troops are doing what they normally do.
And the staff thinks that we're talking tactics.
We weren't talking tactics.
We're talking Al Hague was telling me when he was in high school.
He got kicked out of school because of smoking.
And at principals to his mother,
you will never become anything.
And so,
I mean, Al Hague got the mood.
Pretty good.
And that's what we're talking about.
And we, we've been saying,
we stay friends until he died.
Okay.
The weather term,
the exercise is canceled.
We did a lot of damage to the German.
Real estate,
big property damage.
And we're going to use back to the field,
back to our locations.
Try not to tear up the Germany streets
because the streets are no longer frozen.
You got tight-skilling over them.
And tight-skilling would do severe damage to anything.
We got back and recovered.
And I like to wait for George to operate so well.
George came in to see me.
Sir, I like to stay with you.
I like to wait for you to operate.
You remember that word I said,
Sir, the first time you ever do that word ever,
when you have to stay on.
Sure, I like to stay here.
Let me call a blanchard.
I call a blanchard.
Sir, George want to stay here.
Hell no, he's going home.
Okay.
I'll go back and tell George.
George,
he's for a commander, said no.
Okay.
So, he goes off and who is this thing?
And the meantime, I start getting in a replacement for him.
The very first one came in when George was leaving.
He was off at the officers club,
at the club in Stuttgart.
And spent the night, his family's going home.
And the next morning,
I, my staff,
other major commanders,
and the band comes out to play welcome him farewell.
The one thing that George really resented when he was the
division commander,
was the Gary Ones,
which is our first cat of it in song,
Calry Song.
And guess what song,
the band played.
George walked us to,
what?
And I almost died because they were about to,
I couldn't do anything about it.
And I never told a bandmaster don't play that.
I thought,
well never mind.
he got in his car and drove off.
That was driver drove off.
Madder and Hill.
And it took me some time to recover that after he got back to the
state, but tried to explain that.
He didn't reach for that.
Did he, he thought I'd better?
So I stayed on the core commander.
The Russia's never attacked.
We were prepared.
We worked very hard.
And when it came time to come home, I came home to training
and doctrine commander.
Okay, Fort Monroe,
Virginia, Virginia.
I was the deputy commander,
the only black American
at that level.
Jack Merritt, my chief of staff from the division,
in the meantime, they going from that position to two star at Fort
still at the commander from that position to the director of the Army,
the joint staff,
a three star billet.
And from that position,
he went to Europe to work to be a representative from the
Fort ambassador and the NATO forces and became a four star.
And so while he is doing that,
he's a three star now.
He's going to be jumping him.
Three star and I'm at the,
he's at Fort Leb Morph at the deputy commander for training
and doctrine commander at Leb Morph.
And I'm the deputy commander for training at Monroe.
He's charged all officer training and I'm in charge of all training centers.
I pointed out because the relationship that we have,
he left the enemy and came to Fort store at Brussels.
I'm back at the Monroe three star billet.
I not only become the deputy commander for training at Fort training at Autor
Command, I become the Army inspector for training,
a new position that the chief of staff of the Army want to try out.
And now not only am I in charge of training,
but I'm also in charge of unit in the field training.
And which means I get a chance to mark up,
not only the training that we conduct for our soldiers,
but also how well they're doing that.
And I get a chance to inspect them units.
That also irritates a few people because they never had one before
until I got that job until I was told to do that.
Again, a racial standpoint.
By that time there are three lieutenant generals.
Roscoe Robinson went to the four star.
Art Gray, who is now the J1 and the joint staff.
And then the commander,
he went to the three star at the Army staff at the G4,
three star billet.
Okay. Roscoe gets promoted.
Art and I stay in our three star billets.
And I stayed at that job until I retired.
Some interesting things are placed during that time.
I had a chance to represent the Army in some interesting positions
that required deal with the public.
I might have before that,
I dealt with, I mentioned deal with the National Guard.
Now I'm dealing with the, what takes place in the field at the highest level,
but the one is the lieutenant general.
I retired from the Army in August of 1983.
And move into the civilian activity,
but still is retired lieutenant general.
Looking for a job as a retired lieutenant general,
was not easy as I thought,
because when I talk to corporations,
I don't have any experience at the corporation level.
I certainly don't have, I'm still, I got a master's, but so what?
I've commanded many units on the ground,
but industry sometime, at that time,
we're not interested in soldiers what they could do.
I finally get a job, AID,
for interested development,
and become the director of,
disaster assistance,
that the United States government have for helping other countries
when they have major problems.
I am now the guy in charge of that.
Okay, I did that job from January of 84,
to the summer of 85.
And doing that period,
I had quite a few disasters,
a major disaster overseas.
My biggest one was the famine in Africa,
and we provided major support there,
and I became the guy in charge of that support,
from all agencies providing support.
The racial thing,
the ambassador from South Africa
came over to request assistance
and the agency director for AID.
Sure, go down and see Colonel General Bechtney,
he'll take care of you.
And I told my secretary,
this is going to be amusing.
Physician said that,
the guy walks in to report to me,
the director,
as for assistance for the African support.
He said,
one look at me,
oh, I forgot something,
and he went out.
And left.
And I call my boss,
the AID,
and say, I think we got a problem,
I don't think he can see him back here.
We didn't.
Because the last thing he expected to see
was a black American in that position
to provide support for him.
Because I want to provide support,
but he will have gotten an earful
of what I think about what his country is doing.
I'm racial standpoint.
He may remember those days.
Absolutely.
Part of what's happening.
What is that?
Hi.
I stay in AID.
We have a lot of interesting work going on.
I did the job quite well.
The agency,
Federal Emergency Management Agency, FEMA.
The highest level in the government
for providing support for the country.
And I had made contact with some interesting people
when I had that job in AID,
one of Vice President,
because of what we did for other countries.
Two, a felony in Gore,
who was then Senator from Tennessee,
and a couple of representatives
on the staff,
on the congressional staff.
And when he came to I'm from meeting going to FEMA,
with no political support,
I had to get somebody to support me.
And I had the Vice President spoke my behalf,
Gore came over and spoke my behalf,
and several other people.
I went through my,
with no sweat at all.
And I became the Director of FEMA.
Most interesting,
because I had a staff,
a political pointee.
And the last thing they expect to see was a soldier coming in,
who had no political background,
as such.
I said, guys, hey, I'm going to do the job.
I'm here to help you, you to help me.
Anything you can do,
anything that I'm not doing right,
tell me about it.
I'll be the first to listen to you.
And we got long, very far.
As a matter of fact,
interesting enough,
we just got Christmas cards from three of those
political pointees this week.
That's a long time ago.
Anyhow, we go on to FEMA,
and we now have all kinds of challenges.
Floods.
I was there less than a week
when major floods took place in
Northern Virginia,
not too far from here.
And I got a,
Warner call, I want this kind of support.
Well, my job was to advise the President,
whether the damage is sufficient,
that we should provide the support
that they're asking for.
And so I got Warner,
came in the helicopter,
using the National Guard,
Virginia National Guard chopper,
we went up to look at the flood,
it's pretty bad.
I mean, it was really bad.
Came back, landed.
I made my report to the President,
approving the recommendation
from the state that they have a declaration of disaster.
And that went through.
And of course, from that time on,
anytime major disaster occurred,
I would be the one who had to recommend to the President.
Yes or no?
Sometimes we said no.
Yes, basically what my staff told me,
because they're the experts.
They're out there on the ground.
Now, FEMA did not go out and do to work themselves.
FEMA's organization to collaborate,
coordinate, make contacts.
But we have nobody can go out and dig a ditch
or do anything else.
We just had to contact,
and we also control those folks on the ground.
And so,
I spent from that time until
1989,
I asked the Director of FEMA,
thoroughly enjoyed it,
had good conti,
made good relations,
and then an interesse in the Thunc heard.
The Governor of,
why was that FEMA?
The Governor of New Hampshire,
Kainan Sunu Nu,
got very irritated way that we were trying to support his
installation of nuclear power plants.
And we were responsible not putting a plan in,
but providing a security for that plan.
And so, we exercised that.
And my staff were not satisfied
the way they were doing it,
so we did not approve it.
And he went,
let's see,
ballistic.
I thought you were meddling with this.
Oh, yeah.
He came down one day into my office
and demanded that I change it.
Governor, I hear what you're saying,
but we're not going to do it until these things are done.
I'm going to the White House.
Be my guest, sir.
He started with the White House,
and they said nothing to me,
because they knew what I was doing.
And by the way, while the Director of FEMA,
I saw the President probably less than a half a dozen times.
I didn't take the papers over to him in person.
My contact with the White House presented my recommendation
to the Chief of Staff there,
and they talked about it and up to the President.
He was me going in front of the President saying,
this is it.
So, he went over and apparently did the same thing,
but didn't get anywhere.
Okay, now,
George Bush become President.
I mean, I stay.
Who did he select for the Vice President?
Where did the Chief of Staff,
John Sonuno,
because his political influence,
New Hampshire, and the importance of the Hamptonist
and Republicans,
and Sonuno now becomes the
Executive Chief of Staff,
to the President.
And he made it clear.
If he ever got a chance to do something to him, he would do it.
Sonuno, it became very clear.
His first action would be
I'm Alabama FEMA.
Now,
the President is stepping in stopping.
But George Bush did something very interesting.
He called me and said,
would you like to be ambassador?
Sir, yes, sir.
And I went home to my wife,
and she was not happy about that,
because she spent enough time being a putt of plan
that she said standing around the corner
as a command, and everyone else is going on.
Now, it's become a ambassador.
And I'm at home listening to this.
I get a call after I no longer direct a FEMA.
Bush did not stop being from
Sonuno from changing me,
from being the direct a FEMA.
But he did make it possible he'd become an ambassador,
because that would not bother Sonuno.
Get a call.
And I'm going to ask you to join us.
The President, he liked,
had to change his mind.
A friend of his,
and the Congress got defeated,
Ed Tewinski,
and he can no longer put you
in the job
of working for administration.
We're going to put you.
And that's when his sub-academy
came about,
who would take over FEMA?
So, Sonuno said,
you got to go.
And I get to call that
after Bush wanted me to go to become an ambassador,
and this guy got selected.
And he was a failure
in the job to follow me in FEMA.
And I could have predicted that.
Love people could have predicted,
but,
and so.
And the ambassador position got taken off the table.
I got taken off the table.
No, my wife took me off that.
Oh.
When I got to call,
I'd go and become an ambassador
to Hawaii,
to Caribbean,
we're not going down there.
Hell no, we're not going,
my wife doesn't swear often,
but we're not going to go down there.
And I told the guy who told me this,
okay, we understand.
And that's terminated my relationship with the White House.
That was it.
And that's when
I became civilian.
Happy to work doing.
I would
been there
not very long before I get this call.
But would you be interested in helping us out?
School system.
District of Columbia.
And I had assumed I would come down and talk about
a board,
because they're trying to set up a board to take over, you know,
and run things.
And as the,
you might remember,
there's a time when the government
will control by a control board.
And the control board is the one that
controls the school system.
And they're the ones that were calling me.
And I thought they want me to become a part of a board to run
the school.
And if they're describing to me this situation,
they're going to be able to do something.
One of the members said,
now when you get there,
whoa, time out.
What do you mean when I get there?
Oh, we want you to become super intended.
Didn't we tell you that?
I thought you said,
you're going to be a part of a board.
No, super intended.
Okay.
I said, well,
let me go home and see how it works out.
As I'm driving home my car and call my wife and say,
I've been offered a job a super intended.
We had moved from Washington,
at home there,
out to Springfield.
We got great relations with the neighbors,
and everything else.
And my wife said,
two conditions.
Don't bring your anger home,
and we're not moving.
That's okay.
I could handle that.
And when I got to the schools,
I made very clear.
No matter what they say,
we're not moving from Virginia.
I know what the rules are,
but you want me at the super intended,
I'm staying here.
This is an emergency.
You said,
I'm staying here.
The control board understood that?
I stayed on.
In Northern Virginia,
Springfield.
I stayed on
a guttained school system.
Now keep in mind,
the only school I've been training I've had
in school with University of President.
We're not all bad,
but we use University of President
and a lot different than running a school.
Also,
I had a system in which
the...
We run dollar money.
We...
And...
We made...
Enemy with the mayor who was under control.
You never heard that name?
He was the mayor,
but he had lost control
because the control board is in.
And when you go before the Congress for school...
Money, I got to go for the schools.
Not the mayor.
So you committed a real time of crisis?
Second.
You came in at a time of crisis?
Yes.
I did.
He...
He had a few challenges, too.
He spent time in jail.
He had a few other things, too.
But I got along with the mayor fine,
up until a point.
When he started getting to my business,
and I said,
Mr. Mayor, that's not your job.
This is my job.
I'm the mayor. Well, fine.
I'm still a superintendent.
You want to control that?
Go to control board.
I got through that,
and come...
has some challenges in the school system.
After being there for about 18 months...
my family had a caucus.
And it said,
Dad,
joyous, my wife,
we're tired.
We're tired of seeing the name Bechton in the press.
We're tired of seeing the beat up.
You're taking the press.
We're tired of that.
You're retired.
Why don't you give it up?
And being a practical man as I am,
would you understand that?
I'm in trouble if I stay home.
Okay.
I report into control board,
into the media.
I'm going to go home,
and become a private citizen.
Why are you leaving to press that?
Hey.
You see what I've been faced with?
You know what I've done?
I'm faced with it.
But I got problems at home,
and I just go,
I'm tired,
and I'm going to go home and enjoy it.
I think I have brought you up to date.
I don't think I've tried that much time.
That was wonderful.
Let me ask just one final question.
This is so much a specific question,
as I asked you to comment about,
because I was struck in your incredible life story,
you know, the number of times that you were the first
or one of very few.
And if you could just sort of comment about a life
led like that.
Well, I've been told that many times,
and I thought about it too.
I found a lot of help.
I mean, the first to admit,
one is from Philip Starris,
and I talked to that.
I've always explained about the help I had with my ankle being
shot up in a misdiagnet,
tended in the bone,
and other things in combat.
And some battles I've had in the political arena,
but I try to be very practical what I'm doing.
I have a very supportive family.
They may move to,
I think if I was a youngster being moved as much as they have,
different schools that go into,
I've been very upset.
They dealt with that.
Financially,
the jobs I have were not all that rewarding,
money-wise.
Famer,
and working for the AID,
I received no retired pay.
As a three-star general,
why,
something, and I went to FEMA,
dual compensation.
I could not draw
salary that a director would get,
and keep retired pay.
Because the federal government has a rule,
you cannot be paid by the federal government for two jobs.
One retired, one there.
That's to be cheap, by the way, since then.
So we're not making a lot of money.
And when I finally left FEMA,
I was able to get a couple boards.
Doing that period, I've gotten,
I ended up joining four corporate boards.
First one was Illinois's tools work,
down in Hitcore's Illinois.
And a fellow named Jack Vessi,
former director, former chairman of the Joint Chiefs Staff,
former division commander,
and a good friend.
Call me and say,
joyous.
How does it feel to be on a board?
Come on, Jack, I'm on a board.
I got enough board now.
This one pays money.
Oh, now that's different.
That one, the second board,
Wacken Hut.
You may have heard about that.
Security.
Sure.
Oh, they ph. Killy.
Marine Corps coming on.
Call me and say, hey,
we need you down here.
There's a position down here.
They never had a black home board before.
We want you to come down to be on the board.
They pay money?
Sure.
Okay.
I joined Wacken Hut.
Next one.
I'm on a Marine Still Response Corporation.
There are the agency that being formed to deal with floods
when a ship has problem with spills.
The big spill took place down the gall.
MS Military Spill Response Corporation.
My contact was there when I was at
trade-off at the Deputy Commander,
the Coast Guard on the Coast Commander was a retired vice admiral.
And he would now,
the president of this new organization,
the Marine Spill Response Corporation.
Sure.
I come out of Jack.
He paid money.
I'll be there.
And the last one was something called GD, General Dynamics.
And I got a call one day from
Thoney and Jack Merritt,
and they were in the bill again.
And another civilian,
who, name it,
I think I've right now,
they were on GD boards.
And they were looking for it.
They never had money.
And had a vacancy.
How's the join us?
Jack, if you say so,
and to pay real money, I'll be happy to.
I joined that board.
GD, Wacken Hut,
Marine Spill Response Corporation.
And I'm really grateful for what you've got there.
But I, yeah.
General Dynamics,
Wacken Hut,
Marine Spill Response Corporation.
It'll come my mind pretty soon.
But we were sitting in Tolokot and financially speaking.
I was able very quickly to fill up my house.
I was at the position I go out and buy two cars,
one for myself, one for my wife,
paying a cash.
And what else can you, you know,
I told my kids are in school,
and John went to doing,
we're just having a great time.
And, you think back in,
in all of those positions,
I was the first black American,
at the corporation,
each of the corporations,
first black American,
the core commander,
first, first, certain, first black to become the Army Inspector Training.
I would not be the first black general for the division commander,
but the second or third,
but that group.
And it's something that we were aware of.
I mean, we, because the family's involved,
well, I don't know what everyone's had,
because I know I was lucky.
I was fortunate to be at the position at the right time.
But so what?
I think that doing, I had those jobs,
I demonstrated that a black American could get the job done.
To me, that was the most important thing.
And we worked very hard,
and when we knew that we were in our microscope,
people were looking what we knew every time we stepped out of line,
we knew it,
and somebody told us about it.
We knew, don't try to do it again.
That's a lot to carry.
What choice did I have?
Go home and sit and drink myself,
go clean, carry your couch,
read someeling.
Get Zuже State General of the Youngsofiah,
then you take it home,
go out there,
leave your room
and talk about suffering.
And that's those financial moments.
But I essentially told them not to come into the city,
but they look down dead.
I spoke about a strong,
whether it's in the corporation or whoever, even a couple of folks from here,
because we developed a relationship with these folks.
It's important to be like people to people with something which I think I do well.
We're sitting in this room right now because the administrator,
deputy administrator, when I saw him, I said, I need a plate, you got this.
Hey, I was told, you got it. You stay here as long as you want.
Okay. When the Fairfax wants to get a radio announcement made,
I got to be the stuckie, what I do that you may have heard over radio about,
about, average height about the Fairfax.
And I went down to radio station in NBC with the woman who's in charge of that
and housing. Matter of fact, I did it and I had heard the tape,
but I never heard the broadcast and one of my friends called me and said,
hey, I just heard your own radio. You didn't want to sound like that.
And I got a call of a small over the country, people who heard it.
That's great. Until my wife heard your own radio, not just tape.
So is that kind of relationship that we have? The Army magazine,
you probably had never seen it. It's a monthly publication,
I'll put it up on the Associated United States Army,
in which the fellow named Jack Murrett was the first publisher,
the second publisher of the fellow named, certain first president,
the second one was the fellow named Gordon Sullivan,
these name-rigabelle. And these are people that I've worked with all of my life
that we have a very good relationship. And I was asked,
there's an article published, which I still have never seen a published
the writer yet, but talk about my efforts back on a Pooh-Syme parameter
and a breakout on a 201 and how what we did made to push through
for the division to get on to where we ended up by doing.
And I didn't do a lot except leave my unit. They thought that I let the charge.
So they published that and the first time I heard about was when
Frint Down in Texas, hey, congratulations. What the hell are you talking about?
You haven't seen Army magazine? No, I haven't. You are taking a look,
pace 19. Is there my picture and a story what I, they said I thought I had done?
Those are the kinds of things which make me feel pretty good about what I've done.
So when I finally go to the great beyond, I think I've done everything
I could do to help myself, my family, and not just rich, but also the country.
Does that answer your question? That is a perfect place. Yes, it answers my question.
It's a perfect, I think, note to end on. So that just leaves me to thank you very much
for your service and for your time. Well, I've had fun doing what I'm doing
because my kitchen of poor, I cannot have fun. I stop doing it.
Have you read in that book I have? I've got a philosophy of command.
There are some 13 points. May 10th Century humor. If I can't do that, I'm in a wrong job.
That's the most important. Yeah. Yeah.
Hey, I enjoyed it. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian
National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Thank you.